GOOD MORNING EVERYONE SORRY FOR
THE LATE START BUT I THINK YOU
ALL KNOW -- THIS IS -- A CRAZY
WEEK -- IN THE IN THE CAPITAL --
I HAD TO OF A MYSELF FOR THINGS
SCHEDULED -- FOR OF THE THE SAME
PERIOD OF TIME WITHIN THIRTY
MINUTES TO ONE ANOTHER -- BUT
I'M HERE NOW AND HOPEFULLY I
WILL GET CALLED TO TO GO -- MAKE
A QUORUM IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THAT'S THE ONLY.
THING THAT'S HANGING OUT THERE
FOR ME -- AND I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE GONNA NEED ME SO THAT'LL
BE OKAY -- WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO -- WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING -- NUMBER OF
TRANSPORTATION -- DEPARTMENTS
BUT WE HAVE A INFORMATION AND
ONLY PRESENTATION ON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION I THINK WE OUGHTA --
BEGIN WITH THAT.
AND I THINK -- WE'RE PLANNING ON
STARTING WITH -- AND LA --
PRESENTATION IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD.
MORNING GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JUST COMPUTERS.
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
I'M AS THOUGH WE I'M GOING TO
JUST MAKE A BRIEF FOR VERBAL
PRESENTATION TO YOU OUR OFFICE
I'M RELEASED A REVIEW OF THE
STATE'S ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM A REPORT -- AT THE
BEGINNING OF MARCH -- AS PART OF
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET PACKAGE
THE SUPPLEMENT ALL.
LANGUAGE REPORT DIRECTED OUR
OFFICE TO REVIEW THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM -- AND
PRESENT SOME FINDINGS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING FUNDED.
THE BENEFITS FROM THOSE PROJECTS
AS WELL AS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM.
I'M JUST A A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND AND THE PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN THE THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
BUDGET AND PACKAGE HAND
CONSOLIDATED SEVERAL SMALLER
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS --
INTO ONE A LARGER PROGRAM THAT
HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING AT
THAT TIME -- FOR AND THE REASON
AT THAT THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED
IN CONSOLIDATING THE SMALLER
ACCOUNTS -- WAS REALLY TO
PROVIDE GREATER FOCUS ON ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AS A MODE OF
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL AS TO
PROVIDE -- AT MORE OF A A STATE
ROLE IN SETTING PRIORITIES FOR
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION WITHIN THE
STATE.
SO IT HAD BEEN ABOUT FIVE YEARS
SINCE THE CREATION OF THE
PROGRAM AND SO THAT WAS SORT OF
IMPETUS -- FOR INCLUDING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET PACKAGE THE
REQUEST OUR OFFICE -- OR THE
DIRECTION TO OUR OFFICE TO TO
REVIEW THE PROGRAM.
SO WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT IN THE
FIVE YEARS SINCE THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IN PLACE THERE HAVE BEEN --
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
DIFFERENT PROJECTS THAT HAVE
RECEIVED SOME FUNDING FROM THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
AND THIS IS BEEN THROUGH VARIOUS --
FUNDING CYCLES WHERE THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION WILL
PUT OUT A CALL FOR PROJECTS --
AND AND FUND PROJECTS IN A
CERTAIN DOLLAR AMOUNT BASED ON
THE FUNDING THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE.
AND 75% OF THOSE PROJECTS ARE
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
THESE TEND TO BE SMALLER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS SO I'M
PUTTING IN A BY CLEAN.
OR A BICYCLE PATH AND BUILDING
SIDEWALKS OR INSTALLING
CROSSWALKS ARE OTHER PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY TYPES OF FEATURES -- BUT
BUT STILL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT THE REMAINING
PROJECTS TEND TO BE FOR PLANNING
AND AND AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT AND SO
THERE'S THERE'S THREE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS TO THE PROGRAM AND
THERE'S A STATE COMPONENT WHICH
GETS 50% OF THE FUNDING.
THERE IS THAT METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATION OR MPO
COMPONENT THAT RECEIVES 40% OF
THE FUNDING AND THERE'S 10% OF
THE FUNDING GOES TO THE SMALL
URBAN AND RURAL REGIONS OF THE
STATE.
AND SO WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
EACH OF THOSE THREE PROGRAM
COMPONENTS TEND TO BE FUNDING
THE SAME TYPES OF PROJECTS --
VERY SIMILAR TYPES OF PROJECTS
VERY SIMILAR -- DOLLARS SIZE OF
THE PROJECTS.
I WE ALSO FOUND THAT THE WHILE
THE PROJECTS ARE.
GENERALLY VERY SMALL AND PUTTING
IN A SIDEWALK OR INSTALLING AT A
BIKE LANE IS NOT TYPICALLY A A
HUGE DOLLAR COST COMPARED TO
OTHER TYPES OF TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE -- BUT THESE
PROJECT DO APPEAR TO BE GETTING
BIGGER OVER TIME -- ONE OF THE
IDEAS WHEN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WAS CREATED IS THAT --
PULLING THE FUNDS TOGETHER WOULD
ALLOW POTENTIALLY ALLOW FOR MORE
LARGER MORE TRANSFORMATIVE TYPES
OF ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THAT WOULD REALLY --
CREATE ENOUGH OF A OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AN AREA TO
ALLOW FOR A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MODE SHIFT TO HAVE MORE
PEOPLE WALKING AND BIKING AND SO
AS YOU SEE SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS GETTING LARGER AND
LARGER OVER TIME.
IT COULD BE REPRESENTATIVE OF
PROJECTS TRENDING TOWARDS BEING
THE ISN'T LARGER MORE
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS.
AND WE'RE SEEING THAT ACROSS THE
THREE DIFFERENT PROGRAM
COMPONENTS SO NOT ONLY THE
STATEWIDE COMPONENT BUT ALSO THE
MPO AND THE SMALL URBAN AND
RURAL COMPONENT.
I'M ANOTHER THING THAT WE WERE
ASKED TO LOOK AT IS WHAT
BENEFITS THESE PROJECTS ARE
ACHIEVING IN THE PROGRAM OVERALL
IS ACHIEVING.
SO OBVIOUSLY A PRIMARY GOAL OF
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM IS TO INCREASE WALKING
AND BIKING I'M UNFORTUNATELY THE
DATA IS NOT BEING COLLECTED ON
THESE OUTCOMES -- FOR THESE
PROJECTS IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT'S
USABLE THERE SOME DATA BEING
COLLECTED BY THE WAY IT'S BEING
COLLECTED AND THE TIMING OF HOW
THE DATA IS BEING COLLECTED.
REALLY WE FOUND MAKING IT YOU
CAN'T REALLY PULL ANY MEANINGFUL
AN OUTCOME.
MEASURES ARE INSIGHTS FROM THAT
DATA AND SO IT'S REALLY UNCLEAR
AT THIS POINT WHETHER OR WALKING
AND BICYCLING IS ACTUALLY BEING
INCREASED BY THE PROGRAM.
ANOTHER OUTCOME THAT WE FOUND --
AND WERE ASKED TO LOOK AT IS ON
THE ON THE IMPACT ON
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SO WE DID FIND THAT MOST
PROJECTS ARE BENEFITING A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY IN SOME
WAY -- THAT COULD BE THE PROJECT
IS WITHIN A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY OR IT COULD BE OUTSIDE
OF A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY BUT
HAS SOME -- LINKAGE OR BENEFIT
TO THAT COMMUNITY BY MAYBE
PROVIDING A CONNECTION OR
SOMETHING -- AND SO 88% OF THE
PROJECTS HAD SOME SORT OF
BENEFIT TO A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY -- WE ALSO KNOW THAT
IN ADDITION TO THE PROJECT CAN
BE OUTSIDE OF A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY BENEFIT.
THE AND THE WAY THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
DEFINED HAS CHANGED SOMEWHAT
THROUGHOUT SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE PROGRAM WITHOUT EACH SORT
OF INTEGRATION OUT OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION'S.
DEVELOPMENT OF GUIDELINES ON AND
IN SOME CASES HAS HAS BEEN
BROUGHT AND AND SO HAVING A
SOMEWHAT BROAD MEASURE OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY -- COULD
ALSO BE ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE'RE SEEING SUCH AS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THE
PROJECTS.
I'M HAVING A BENEFIT TO THE
DISCIPLINE COMMITTEE BUT DOES
APPEAR TO BE MEETING THAT GOAL
FOR THE PROGRAM THAT STATURE
TRICKLE.
THAT THE STATUTE PROVIDES A
MINIMUM OF 25% SO IT'S IT'S WELL
IN EXCESS OF THAT.
AS WE WERE ASKED TO LOOK
SPECIFICALLY WHETHER THERE'S
MAJOR BENEFITS TO THE STATE
pCAN BE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ON THAT BENEFIT THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM WHERE YOU
HAVE A STATE HIGHWAY THAT.
ESSENTIALLY TURNS INTO MAIN
STREET OF A OF A CITY WHEN IT'S
RUNNING THROUGH IT AS A TOWN.
AND WE WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY DATA
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME WE
PREPARED THIS REPORT TO TO
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY OF THOSE
PROJECTS -- BUT THEY WOULD JUST
BE COMPETING FOR THE PROGRAM THE
SAME AS THE OTHER PROJECTS OF
THERE'S NO SPECIFIC CARVE OUT.
TO BENEFIT OR NOT BENEFIT THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
I'M AND THEN WE FOUND THAT SOME
OF THE OTHER GOALS AND BENEFITS
I'M A SIMILAR TO THE WALKING AND
BIKING ARE ARE DIFFICULT TO
EVALUATE.
AND DATA ON SAFETY IMPROVE
OUTCOMES IS NOT AVAILABLE.
ON THE SOME OF THE OTHER
BENEFITS SUCH AS GHG REDUCTION
OR PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES ARE
GENERALLY GOING TO BE DRIVEN OFF
AS THE DATA AVAILABLE ON
INCREASED WALKING AND BIKING --
SINCE THE GHG REDUCTIONS WOULD
COME FROM A MODE SHIFT OF PEOPLE
WHO CHOOSE TO NO LONGER DRIVE
AND INSTEAD TAKE AN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION ABOUT.
SO WITHOUT THAT DATA IT'S REALLY
HARD TO TELL SOME OF THESE OTHER --
SORT OF TERTIARY -- BENEFITS
THAT THE PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO
ACHIEVE.
AB WE ARE ALSO ASKEDTO LOOK AT
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES AND
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION.
SO WE FOUND THAT AND THE
APPLICATION SCORING PROCESS AND
THAT THE CDC HAS SAT AT I'M
INTERESTED MAYBE BE SOMEWHAT
DUPLICATIVE IT'S AND I'M.
A QUICK REQUIRE SORT OF A A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFORT AND SO FOR
ALL OF THE EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
THESE AND THREE SEPARATE POTS OF
MONEY FOR THE PROGRAM WITH THE
MPO AND THE SMALL URBAN AND
RURAL POT.
AS WELL AS THE STATEWIDE
COMPONENT -- IT ANY PROJECT
WANTING TO COMPETE FOR ANY OF
THOSE THREE POTS HAS TO FIRST
COMPETE IN THE STATE WIDE
PROGRAM.
WHICH MEANS FILLING OUT AN
APPLICATION AND APPLYING TO THE
CTC AND GOING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS AND THEN PROJECTS THAT
DON'T RECEIVE FUNDING THROUGH
THAT PROCESS -- WHAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO COMPETE IN THE MPO
AND COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM IF
THEY'RE LOCATED WITHIN THAT
REGION -- AND SO THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND IS IS
IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT CTC SCORES
THESE PROJECTS THAT WITH OUR AND
STAFF THEY ALSO USE VOLUNTEERS
TO SCORE THE PROJECTS.
AND THERE COULD BE SOME
INCONSISTENCIES THERE THE
PROCESS DOES SEEM A LITTLE BIT
DUPLICATIVE AND SO JUST KEEPING
THAT IN BACK OF MIND AS YOU
THINK ABOUT CHANGES YOU MIGHT
WANT TO MAKE TO THE PROGRAM.
THAT HOW IS THAT GOING TO AFFECT
THE THE C. D. C.'S OVERALL
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
SO IN TERMS OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE AND
THAT SORT OF THE FIRST AND MOST
OBVIOUS ONE IS REQUIRE BETTER
DATA COLLECTION -- WE ARE ASKED
TO LOOK AT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS PROGRAM THE SHORT ANSWER IS
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T DATA TO SHOW THE KEY.
METRIC OF IS THIS INCREASING
WALKING OR BIKING THERE IS SOME
DATA BEING COLLECTED THE QUALITY
OF THE DATA FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS WE THOUGHT WAS SO POOR
THAT IT REALLY WASN'T USABLE IN
SOME CASES IT GAVE
COUNTERINTUITIVE RESULTS AND IT
JUST DIDN'T REALLY MAKE SENSE
AND SO WE REALLY.
THOUGHT THAT WAS.
THE QUALITY OF THE DATA I'M
CALTRANS NOTED IN AND ONE OF
THEIR UPDATE REPORTS SIMILAR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA.
SO THAT WOULD BE THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION IS JUST YOU KNOW
INSURE THAT THE PROGRAM IS
COLLECTING GOOD DATA SO YOU CAN
EVALUATE THE OUTCOMES.
I'M A COLLECTING IN A ROBUST
DATA ON PEDESTRIAN AND
BICYCLISTS COUNTS.
CAN BE EXPENSIVE AND IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A REALLY SMALL
PROJECT IT MIGHT NOT MAKE SENSE
IN ALL OF THOSE CASES AND SO
YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT PROJECTS.
DOES THAT MAKE THE MOST SENSE TO
COLLECT THIS DATA ON AND HAVE.
A MEANINGFUL BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN COUNTS AND WHICH
PROJECTS DO YOU JUST YOU KNOW
SAY.
WERE FIXING THE SMALL AREA OF
SIDEWALK AND THAT'S A GOOD THING
TO DO BUT MAYBE IT'S NOT WORTH
GOING THROUGH THE WHOLE PROCESS
OF AS I'M DOING THESE YOU KNOW
MORE AND MORE LENGTHY AND COUNTS.
SO IT THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE HAVE IS REALLY TO JUST
CONSIDER WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
STATEWIDE COMPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM SO IN THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WAS.
CREATED AGAIN THAT THE IDEA WAS
TO GIVE THE STATE'S SAM ROLE IN
SETTING PRIORITIES.
I'M AND BRING GREATER FOCUS TO
THE PROGRAM AND SO.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE STATE RIGHT
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM AND
COMPARE IT TO THE REGIONAL
COMPONENTS THE MPO -- AND THE
SMALL URBAN AND RURAL WE'RE
FINDING THE SAME TYPES OF
PROJECTS ACROSS ALL THREE OF
THESE COMPONENTS.
AND SO IT REALLY SEEMS THAT EACH
OF THE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS ARE
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO MEET THE
SAME GOALS.
I'M AND WE'RE NOT SEEING A REAL
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF WHY THE STATE AS HAVING A
ROLE IN SELECTING CERTAIN
PROJECTS WHEN WE OVER ALL SEEM
TO BE FINDING THE SAME TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE FUNDED IF.
WE WERE ALLOWING -- REGIONS TO
JUST CHOOSE THE PROJECTS
THEMSELVES.
AND SO YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THERE CAN
DEFINITELY BE BENEFITS OF HAVING
A STATEWIDE ROLE AND STATE
PRODUCT SELECTION AND
PRIORITIZATION.
THERE CAN BE THESE LARGER
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT.
AND YOU KNOW ARE REALLY GOING TO
BE THE THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO
LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT MODE SHIFT.
AND BUT I SPANIEL SMALL
COMMUNITY IT MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO AFFORD THAT PROJECT ON THEIR
OWN AND SO HAVING A YOU KNOW A
POT OF FUNDING THROUGH THE STATE
RIGHT COMPONENT. TO REALLY PUT
PUT A LOT MORE MONEY THAN ANYONE
CITY OR JURISDICTION COULD MAYBE
PUT INTO A PROJECT COULD BE A
REAL BENEFIT AND THAT WAY TO
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE IN TERMS OF
ALL WHY IS THE STATE INVOLVED IN
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING THINGS.
THAT THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO OTHERWISE --
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
TO CONSIDER YOUCOULD HAVE A
DIFFERENT ROLE FOR THE STATE
RIGHT COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM
BUT WHEN WE LOOKED AT IT GIVEN
THE RATIONALE ON THE REASONS WHY
THE PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
FOCUSING THAT PIECE ON THESE
LARGER MORE TRANSFORMATIVE
PROJECTS SEEM TO MAKE A LOT MORE
SENSE TO US.
SO THEN IF IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT POSSIBLY CHANGING WHAT
THAT FOCUS OF THE STATEWIDE
COMPONENT OF THE PROGRAM GOES
TILL.
THEN IT ALSO YOU'RE GONNA WANT
TO THINK ABOUT HOW HOW ARE YOU
CHANGING POTENTIALLY THE
REGIONAL COMPONENTS OF THE
PROGRAM -- IF THE STATE'S
FOCUSING ON THESE LARGER
PROJECTS SHOULD THE REGION'S
HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO FOCUS
ON EITHER SMALLER PROJECTS OR
JUST OTHER PROJECTS THAT FROM
THEIR REGIONAL PERSPECTIVE ARE
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY PROJECTS.
AND SO THAT'S THE LAST
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE JUST
THINK YOU SHOULD CONSIDER GIVING
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO THE M. P.
O.'S.
ON AS YOU THINK ABOUT MAKING
THESE POTENTIALLY STRUCTURAL
CHANGES OF HOW THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM FUNDING
GOES OUT AND WHAT GOALS TO
DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY ARE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
YOU'RE GONNA NATURALLY WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES OF
HOW THE PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED --
IF YOU HAVE THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF THE PROGRAM TRYING
TO MEET DIFFERENT GOALS WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO THE MPO THIS PROBABLY DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO HAVE ALL OF THE
APPLICATIONS FLOWING THROUGH CTC.
AND HAVING THEM COMPETE FOR A
PROGRAM THAT REALLY THOSE
PROJECTS MAYBE OUR TICKET.
FOR FOR AND SO WE THINK YOU'RE
GONNA WANT TO THINK ABOUT
REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU DO MAYBE
GIVING SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
THE PO'S -- THAT COULD BE DONE
BY AND JUST GIVING THEM MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO CHOOSE PROJECTS
AND NOT RESTRICTING THEM TO THE
LIST OF PROJECTS THAT FIRST
COMPETE AND DON'T RECEIVE
FUNDING TO THE STATE PROGRAM.
I'M OR COULD BE DONE BY A GIVING
ALMOST MORE OF LIKE A BLOCK
GRANT TO THE M. PO'S AND LETTING
THEM JUST CHOOSE THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR THE REGION.
AND THEN PUTTING SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS -- ON THOSE REGIONS
TO TO LET THE STATE NOW WHAT WAS
DONE WITH THE FUNDS AND WHAT THE
OUTCOMES WERE -- SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND A SUMMARY OF A REPORT AND I
AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW
WHEN WE MOVE ON TO THE MR FONG
SORRY.
A JUST A CURIOSITY IN TERMS OF
THE DATA COLLECTION -- HOW IS IT
DONE NOW?
HOW IS IT A COLLECTED WHAT
QUESTIONS THEY ASK I'M JUST?
SO CURRENTLY AND THAT THERE ARE.
AT IN SOME CASES THERE'S AND
PEDESTRIAN BICYCLIST COUNTS
HAPPENING BEFORE THE PROJECT
JUST AT SOME POINT BEFORE THE
PROJECT IS DONE.
AND THEN WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF
COMPLETION OF THE PROJECT OF
THERE IS THAT -- PROJECT
AND SO -- SOME OF THE ISSUE SOME
PROJECTS JUST DIDN'T DO THE
BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN COUNT
MANY OF THEM DEAD THE PROBLEM IS
THAT AND THERE WAS INCONSISTENT
METHODOLOGIES.
SO AND WE WERE GIVEN ONE AND
SAMPLE PROJECT TO LOOK AT AND IN
THAT CASE THE BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN COUNT THAT IT
HAPPENED.
BEFORE THE PROJECT AND THIS WAS
A PROJECT AND TO INCREASE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AROUND A
PARTICULAR SCHOOL.
AND SO THAT PROJECT -- THAT THE
COUNTS BEFOREHAND DID A SURVEY
OF THE PARENTS AND IT WAS LIKE
IT LATE SUMMER SO PROBABLY
AROUND THE VERY START OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR.
AND WHEN THE WEATHER WAS
PROBABLY GOOD AND THE
METHODOLOGY WAS TO SURVEY THE
PARENTS AND SAY HEY WALKIE
HAVING YOUR KIDS WALK TO SCHOOL
IS A GREAT THING HOW YOU KNOW
HOW MANY.
HOW HOW OFTEN YOUR KIDS WALK IN
SO THERE CAN BE SOME IMPLICIT
BIAS THAN IN THE THE THE
METHODOLOGY USED?
AS WELL AS THE WEATHER AND THE
TIMING YOU KNOW THE START OF
SCHOOL MAYBE MORE KIDS ARE
WALKING.
THE FOLLOW UP WITHIN SIX MONTHS
LATER IN THE MIDDLE OF WINTER --
WHERE YOU KNOW MAYBE THE WEATHER
WAS GOOD BUT MAYBE NOT -- IT'S
REALLY UNCLEAR AND THE
METHODOLOGY WAS DIFFERENT IN
THAT CASE THERE WAS --
STATIONARY CAMERAS THAT WERE IN
THE AREA AND THOSE WERE USED TO
DO MANUAL COUNTS OF THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN THAT WERE WALKING ON
THE CAMPUS.
AND SORT OF AND SURPRISINGLY IT
SHOWS THAT THE PROJECT RESULTED
IN LESS AFTER FOR INTERPRETATION
BUT THOSE RESULTS ARE REALLY
MEANINGFUL BECAUSE THERE IS SO
MUCH INCONSISTENCY IN THE
METHODOLOGY THAT.
DOESN'T.
SO THERE SHOULD BE A UNIFORM AT
THE DOLLAR TREE AND AND
EVALUATING ALL THESE PROJECTS
EXACTLY AND ALLOWING ENOUGH TIME
LIKE RIGHT NOW WITH HAVING THAT
THE COMPLETION REPORTS DO WITHIN
SIX MONTHS -- THAT MIGHT NOT BE
ENOUGH TIME FOR USERS TO
ACTUALLY MAKE A CHANGE TO DECIDE --
HE THERE'S THIS REALLY NICE BIKE
PATH I'M GOING TO USE IT -- AND
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO BE
LOOKING AT MAYBE THE SAME TIME
OF YEAR -- SINCE YOU KNOW ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION IS GONNA BE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
THE WEATHER.
THE OTHER BEST PRACTICES THAT
EXIST.
IN OTHER A GRANT MATTER TO ME
FEEL FREE TO CHIME AND I'M I'M
I'M.
GATHERING INFORMATION JUST
TRAILER -- MY NAME IS SUSAN
BRANSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I'M HERE AT LAURIE
WATERS THE COMMISSION CHECK TO
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MANAGER.
AND WITH REGARD TO THE OUTCOMES
OF THIS PROGRAM.
IT IS A CONCERN THAT WE SHARE
WITH THE LA L. THE PROJECTS ARE
JUST NOW FROM THE FIRST CYCLE OF
FUNDING.
COMING TO COMPLETION AND SO WE
RECEIVED OUR FIRST REPORT FROM
CALTRANS LAST YEAR.
AND SO IN LIGHT OF WHAT WE KNOW
A WE ARE WORKING WITH CALTRANS
AFTER TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS T. HAVE UNIFORM.
DATA COLLECTION AND REPORTING WE
ALSO THROUGH THE STATE WIDE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
THERE IS A FINDING THAT THE
COMMISSION -- DEDICATES TO AN
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE
CENTER AND THROUGH THAT RESOURCE
CENTER -- WE ARE AT WE HAVE
FUNDED FOR THE RESOURCE CENTER
TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING AND
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING.
UNIFORM COUNTER METHODOLOGY --
TOOL.
THAT ESSENTIALLY WILL BE USED --
AND CHECKED OUT BY AGENCIES ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS PROGRAM.
THEY CAN BORROW THIS TOOL AND GO
OUT AND CONDUCT THEIR USER
ACCOUNTS AND THAT SHOULD
STANDARDIZE INCREASED UNIFORMED
DATA.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THE DATA COLLECTION
METHODOLOGIES ACCOUNT FOR
SEASONAL VARIATIONS AND OTHER
FACTORS.
THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE THAT WE WE
ARE VERY THANKFUL FOR THE LA US
REPORT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN ON OUR YOU KNOW VERY
CONCERNING TO THE COMMISSION
THAT WE ARE ADDRESSING.
SHE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- AND WE
HAVE A QUESTION FROM.
MS RIVER SEND THEM AS GARCIA.
MY QUESTION WAS IF ANY OF THESE
EIGHTY P. -- PROJECTS TARGET
AREAS NEAR SCHOOLS I KNOW YOU
JUST MENTION AN EXAMPLE BUT IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WE ENCOURAGE
OR THE WE TRACK IF.
IF THESE PROJECTS ARE NEAR
SCHOOLS.
I'M YES SO.
AND AND IN MY BRIEF DESCRIPTION
OF THE SETTING UP OF THE PROGRAM
AND IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE
COMPLICATED SO WHEN THERE WERE
DIFFERENT AND SMALLER PROGRAMS
INITIALLY ONE OF THOSE WAS A
SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
AND SO THAT WAS COMBINED.
AND THEIR CERTAIN THE MONEY'S
THERE THAT AND YOU.
HAVE TO BE USED FOR THAT SO IT'S
AND THE YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE'S
FLEXIBILITY AND DISCRETION FOR
THE COMMISSION TO BE ABLE TO
PICK THE PROJECTS THAT ARE THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY BUT WITHIN THAT
THERE'S ALSO SOME SORT OF
SMALLER.
SUB.
POTS OF MONEY OR SUB PROGRAMS
AND SO YES THAT IS DEFINITELY A
FOCUS OF THE PROGRAM IN AND OUT
OF MISPRINTS AND HAS MORE.
TO YEAH I WOULD WANT TO ASSURE
YOU SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOLS IS A
KEY A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
PROGRAM.
LAURIE HAS SOME STATISTICAL
INFORMATION ON THAT.
YES BECAUSE THE THE INITIAL
LEGISLATION AND CREATED THE
PROGRAM IT ACTUALLY MENTIONS
SPECIFICALLY THAT -- TO
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO WALK AND
BIKE SO AND OUR EVALUATION
PROCESS WE ACTUALLY GIVE
ADDITIONAL POINTS FOR PROJECTS
THAT BENEFIT STUDENTS.
AND I WOULD SAY AT LEAST ABOUT
25% OF OUR PROJECTS AND EVERY
CYCLE OUR SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL
PROJECTS.
THIS GARCIA.
YEAH.
WHAT HAPPENS IF AN ORGANIZATION
pTHE DATA AND SHARING IT WITH
EVEN IF IT WAS AND THE BEST
PRACTICES BUT SOMEONE NOT EVEN
COLLECTING THE DATA WHAT HAPPENS?
THEN. TO TO THE ORGANIZATION IS
THERE ANY SORT OF CONSEQUENCE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M I I WILL I WILL LET THAT
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION ANSWER
THAT ONE JUST SINCE THEY'RE MORE
INVOLVED WITH SETTING WHAT DATE
IT BUT I THINK.
PART OF THE ISSUE IS JUST THE
WAY THAT THAT.
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO REPORT
IT WITHIN THE SIX MONTH TIME
PERIOD REALLY DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
SOME OF THESE BEST PRACTICES.
AND SO.
THERE EAT YOU YOU COULD HAVE A
PROJECT SPONSOR THAT IS TRYING
TO DO EVERYTHING RIGHT AND MEET
ALL THE REQUIREMENTS AND THE
STILL AND THAT PROVIDING DATA
THAT'S KINDA USELESS.
AND LET'S NOT USE I MEAN I GET
THE USELESS DATA PURPOSE SO THEY
TRY TO I'M NOT TRYING TO TING ON
THAT BUT THEN YOU HAVE FOLKS
THAT DIDN'T PROVIDE ANY DATA I'M
ASKING ABOUT THOSE PEOPLE THAT
HE DIDN'T EVEN TRY.
SURE YEAH SO A IT SOMEWHERE IT
DIFFICULT ONCE YOU'VE ALREADY
FUNDED THE PROJECT BUT I WILL
LET AND THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SPEAK TO THE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS AND CONSEQUENCES ON
THAT.
AS OF JUNE YEAH I'VE I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY THAT -- THERE IS NOT A
STANDARDIZED WAY TO COLLECT DATA
ANYWHERE SO TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM IS STATE
OF THE ART IS NOT ANOTHER.
PROGRAM.
LIKE THIS IN THE COUNTRY SO.
THERE ARE NOT STANDARDIZED WAYS
TO COLLECT DATA SO AND SUSAN HAD
MENTIONED WE ARE WORKING THROUGH
THE H. D. ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
RESOURCE CENTER.
AND OUR TECHNICAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO COME UP WITH THE
STANDARDIZED WAYS.
AND SO.
IT ANOTHER ISSUE WITH THE DATA
IS SOME OF THESE FACILITIES ARE
BRAND NEW FACILITIES SO THEY'RE
NOT THERE YET SO THERE'S NO WAY
TO COLLECT DATA ON SOMETHING
THAT IS HASN'T BEEN BUILT YET.
SO THE WAY THAT THE APPLICANT
HAS TO TRY TO COME UP WITH DATA
IS FIND A MAYBE LIKE A PARALLEL
ROUTE THAT THEY CAN USE AS AS A
PROXY FOR WHAT THE WHAT THE
FACILITY WILL WILL DO AFTER IT'S
BUILT.
SO I WOULD SAY AT THIS POINT
THERE ARE NO CONSEQUENCES.
FOR A APPLICANT THAT DOES NOT
PROVIDE DATA BUT WE WE WILL WE
HAVE A REPORTING PROCESS AND
WE'RE WORKING ON GETTING.
ALL OF THE REPORTS IN ON TIME
AND ACCURATE.
AND IF I COULD FOLLOW UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THE
COMMISSION HAS STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
GUIDELINES IN PLACE.
WITHIN THIS PROGRAM AND JUST AS
AN OVERALL ACCOUNTABILITY
GUIDELINES THE COMMISSION HAS
ADOPTED.
IT CALLS FOR AUDITS OF THESE
AGENCIES IT CALLS FOR A REGULAR
REPORTING AND WHEN THE REGULAR
REPORTING IS NOT OCCURRING WE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT -- WHERE THERE
IS NON COMPLIANCE?
OVERALL WITH THE EXPENDITURES OF
THESE FUNDS YES A EIGHT
ORGANIZATION RECEIVES THE FUNDS.
AND DOES NOT -- COMPLY YOU KNOW
THE SCOPE.
OF THE PROJECT BILL TO DIFFERENT
PROJECT YOU KNOW THERE'S IF
THERE'S A REPAYMENT MECHANISM IN
PLACE IN THE STATE TO REAP
RETURN THOSE FUNDS.
IN THE CASE OF THE PERFORMANCE
BENEFITS BECAUSE THIS IS A NEW
PROGRAM.
WE NEED TO WORK WITH ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE
HAVE THAT GROUNDED --
METHODOLOGY IN PLACE THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS AND WE
PROVIDE THE TOOLS SO THAT THEY
CAN -- THESE AGENCIES CAN -- YOU
KNOW CAPTURE THE DATA THAT THEY
NEED TO REPORT BUT THE
TIMELINESS OF REPORTING.
IS AN ISSUE AND WE EXPECT OUR
REPORTING TO HAPPEN TIMELY.
ARE WE DO BRING THESE REPORTS TO
THE COMMISSION MEETING.
AND THE CONSIDER THOSE SO
CALTRANS IS REALLY THE AGENCY
THAT IS SPEARHEADING THE
REPORTING.
AND I KNOW THAT THEY ARE ON TOP
OF IT -- AND SO I HAVE -- I HAVE
ONE OF THESE PROJECTS THAT THIS.
GOT IMPLEMENTED IN THE CITY I
LIVE IN -- AND THE RESULT OF IT
HAS BEEN TROUBLING TO SCENE BUT
THEY DID IT'S UNDER THIS YEAR'S
CORRIDOR AND WE DO HAVE SCHOOLS
THERE -- BOTH ELEMENTARY MIDDLE
SCHOOLS ON THAT THIS YEAR'S
CORRIDOR THEY RECENTLY INCREASED
THE SPEED LIMIT TO FORTY MILES
PER HOUR ON THAT FOR THEIR
CONSTRUCTS ARE MOVING THROUGH
THEIR BRAVERY.
AND SO THEY PUT UP A COUPLE OF
SIGNS TELLING US TO SHARE THE
ROAD WITH THE CYCLIST.
AND THEY AND THEY PAINTED THE
BICYCLE LIKE THIS IS NOW SHERRY
LANE BUT THERE'S NOTHING ELSE
THAT WAS ADDED ON TO THE PROJECT.
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO DIVISION
THERE'S NO SPACE AND IT'S A
PRETTY.
HAVE A GOOD CAR DOOR -- I GOT
THE LETTER WHEN THEY RECEIVED A
GRANT THAT'S WHY I KNEW WAS
COMING.
I WROTE THE LETTER IN SUPPORT
BUT IT IS TROUBLING TO ME TO SEE
THEN HOW IS BEING IMPLEMENTED --
IN MY HOME TOWN OR TAKE A WE'RE
TRYING TO GET FOLKS.
TO WALK AND RIDE THE BIKES
INCLUDING THE KIDS LIKE THERE'S
NOTHING AND HOW THIS IS
IMPLEMENTED.
THAT WOULD RESULT IN THAT AS AND
YOU KNOW.
I AND SO MUCH IS THE DATA BUT
THEN TRACKING MAKE IT I AT THE
DATA WILL HELP US WITH THAT DOWN
THE ROAD RIGHT I GET IT TO THE
DATA WILL SHOW.
THERE'S NO IMPROVEMENT BUT IT'S
ALSO LIKE SHOULD THIS PROJECT
EVEN HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED THIS
WAY OUR CONCERNS THAT I HAVE
ABOUT A MAKING SURE.
WE ARE -- GETTING OUR MONEY'S
WORTH -- IN CITIES LIKE MINE I
HAVE THIS ADVANTAGE CITIES
THAT'S YOU KNOW PART OF THESE.
ARE URBAN COMMUNITIES ARE LESS
THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
IT'S COMMUNITIES IF I TO MAKE
SURE WE GET OUR FAIR SHARE AND
SO WE'RE DOING MORE OF THAT HERE
AT THE CAPITOL BUT AND WHAT
EVERY DAY TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
NOT.
JUST YOU KNOW -- PRETENDING TO
BE DAYS THAT THAT'S WHAT IT FELT
LIKE WHEN I THOUGHT IT WAS
DISAPPOINTING TO SEE AN AND WE
SHARE THAT THE DATA IS CRITICAL
RIGHT NOW THE DATA IS OUR OUR
KEY FOCUS.
AND IS SOMETHING THAT -- THE
COMMISSION HAS DEDICATED THROUGH
THE STATE WHAT COMPONENT FUNDING.
FOR FOR THESE DATE ACCOUNTS IN
MEASURES AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
CALTRANS BECAUSE THIS LESSON
THAT YOU JUST SHARED WITH THIS
IS A LESSON THAT WE LEARNED AND
WE CANNOT COME CANNOT REPEATED.
SO IT MAY REQUIRE IT LIKELY WILL
REQUIRE THAT WE ASK DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS ABOUT PROJECTS WHEN
THEY ARE NOMINATED FOR FUNDING.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW IT THIS
PROGRAM AT EATEN EVERY CYCLE
WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK TOWARDS
IMPROVING THE PROGRAM.
AND THE EARLY AS REPORT IS A KEY
REPORT THAT WE WILL USE IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS MOVING FOR IT.
AND THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
SHARED WILL LOOK INTO YOUR
PROJECT AND I WILL.
MAKE SURE MY STEP GETS YOU THE
PICTURES TO THE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TAKEN PICTURES OF WHAT THIS
PROJECT TURNED OUT TO BE OKAY
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT LET'S UP PAUSE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND THAT --
TAKE UP THE OF WHAT ONLY
CALENDAR.
BLOOM HERE FONG.
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
PREVIOUS YEAR.
WE HAVE THE TO VOTE ONLY --
VOTES -- WILL -- HANDLE ITEM ONE
SEPARATELY IS OUR MOTION ON ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE WE HAVE [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible] THREE ONE
I SEE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA DO
ISSUE TO SEPARATELY SO IS THERE
A MOTION ON ISSUE [inaudible]
TO THEIR SECOND.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA HI MULLIN PATTERSON.
RIGHT YES -- REBUS.
NOW I'D LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE REMAINING ITEMS
WHICH WOULD THAT BE ISSUES ONE
AND ISSUES THREE THROUGH.
TWELVE BLOOM HI FONG
[inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
REVERSE.
GREAT THANK YOU SO -- BACK TO
YOU I THINK YOU PROBABLY COVERED
SOME OF YOUR TALKING POINTS IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE QUESTIONS BUT
YOU NEEDN'T REPEAT YOURSELF --
MISTER MULLINS HER WHEN WE LET
HIM OUT ON AND THEN WE'LL. FOR
EFFICIENCY SAKE WILL BE DONE
WITH THAT PART OF THE CALENDAR.
MR MILLER WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW
YOU TO ADD ON AND THE OF VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR NOW AND THEN
YOU'LL BE COMPLETELY CAUGHT UP.
WILL BE COMPLETELY [inaudible]
THE COULD BE A FIRST
[inaudible]
YEAH PLEASE.
SO ISSUES ONE AND THREE THREE
TWELVE THERE WAS A MOTION TO
APPROVE.
MULLIN.
IN ISSUE TWO ALSO A MOTION TO
APPROVE MULLIN.
GREAT.
THANK YOU.
AND SO AND I DID HAVE A FEW AND
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE ACT TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TODAY -- I THINK WE'VE
ADDRESSED SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT I I WANTED TO SHARE WITH
YOU BUT I JUST WANTED -- TO
AGAIN THANK THE LA OF FOR THE
REVIEW AND AS I I ALSO WANTED TO
ASSURE YOU THAT.
WE DO AT THE COMMISSION WITH
EACH FUNDING CYCLE MOVE FOR TO
TO WORK TO IMPROVE WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST.
AND SO WE WILL TAKE THE LA --
RECOMMENDATIONS OF FORD FOR FOR
A ROBUST DISCUSSION IN THE NEXT
CYCLE OF FUNDING I DID WANT TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMISSION SCORING.
OF PROJECT APPLICATIONS WITH YOU
TODAY -- YOU KNOW WE HAD
REQUIRED FOR THE FIRST TIME THE
NPOS TO FIRST APPLY IN THE
STATEWIDE COMPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM. FOR FUNDING -- IT WAS
JUST HAPPENED THIS FIRST THIS
LAST TIME AND THE REASON WAS TO
IMPROVE OUR DATA COLLECTION.
EFFORTS WE WERE HAVING SOME
DIFFICULTIES WITH THAT IN THAT
AREA SO THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAD PUT IN PLACE FOR THE
FIRST TIME BUT IN LIGHT OF THE
EARLY AS A REPORT.
WE WILL WORK WITH EVERYONE ON
THAT AND AND IT JUST AS
NECESSARY.
AS FAR AS THE DUPLICATIVE
PROCESS THE COMMISSION UTILIZES
THE MULTI DISCIPLINARY ADVISORY
TEAM AS REQUIRED IN STATUTE TO
REVIEW THE APPLICATIONS.
ARE THE COMMISSION STAFF DOES
REVIEW EVERY APPLICATION FOR
PURPOSES OF NORMALIZING THE
SCORING.
IN ENSURING CONSISTENCY ACROSS
ACROSS A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
REVIEW TEAMS -- WHERE THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT DEVIATIONS IN THE
COMMISSION STAFF SCORING FROM
THAT MULTI DISCIPLINARY ADVISORY --
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS THE
COMMISSION STAFF IS MEETING WITH
THOSE TEAMS AND RESOLVING THOSE
DISCREPANCIES AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT PROCESS IS NECESSARY
AGAIN TO NORMALIZING ENSURE
CONSISTENCY OF SCORING.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
APPLICATIONS SO THAT -- WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
THE APPLICATIONS ARE YOU VALUE
IS CONSISTENTLY.
WE'VE DISCUSSED AT LENGTH THE
PROGRAM OUTCOMES SO I WON'T AND
I WON'T REPEAT WHAT WE ALREADY
DISCUSSED WITH RESPECT TO
PROJECTS SIZES.
DID WANT TO LET YOU KNOW WOULD
YOU AGREE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF TREAT LARGE
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS.
THE COMMISSION IN THE LAST CYCLE
DID REALLY ENCOURAGE --
APPLICATIONS THAT WOULD BE BRING
AFFORD PROJECTS THAT ARE LARGE
AND TRANSFORMATIVE IN THIS STATE
WHITE COMPONENT.
AND SO AS A RESULT THE
COMMISSION DID FIND MORE LARGE
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS MORE
THAN IT EVER HAS.
BUT THE ENTIRE STATEWIDE PROGRAM
HAS NOT BEEN DIRECTED TO LARGE
TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS BECAUSE
THE COMMISSION HAS WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SMALL URBAN
AND RURAL PARTS.
OF THE STATE ARE WELL SERVED
ENOUGH FORGOTTEN IN THAT IN THAT
COMPONENT.
AND IN THE OVERALL PROGRAM.
IN THE LAST THREE I JUST ON THE
WITH REGARD -- TO PROVIDING A
LUMP SUM TO THE METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS.
WE ARE.
WE AGREE WITH THE LA -- THAT IF
THE LUMP SUM IF TRUMPS SUMS WERE
GIVEN TO THE REGIONAL COMPONENT
IT WOULD REMOVE FROM THE
COMMISSION'S PROJECT LEVEL
OVERSIGHT -- THAT IT CURRENTLY
HAS.
AND THIS COULD HAVE IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE SENATE BILL ONE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF REQUIREMENTS
AS WELL AS THE COMMISSION'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
GUIDELINES.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THE EXAMPLE OF
A PROJECT RIGHT NOW THE
COMMISSION IS REQUIRING TIMELY
IS A FUND SET OF PROJECTS DON'T
MOVE FOR TIMELY -- THE THE
PROJECT SPONSOR FORFEIT SAYS
FUNDS AND THE FUNDS CAN BE
REDIRECTED TO PROJECT THAT IS
READY TO MOVE FORWARD.
SO OVERALL I JUST WANTED TO
ASSURE YOU KNOW YOU ALL THE THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE COMMISSION
TAKES THIS PROGRAM VERY
SERIOUSLY.
WITH EACH CYCLE ARE WORKING TO
IMPROVE IT.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S MORE TO
BE DONE AND WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THE RESOURCES THAT YOU HAVE
GIVEN TO THE COMMISSION SO FAR.
TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THIS
PROGRAM SO THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS THANK THANK YOU THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME IS REYES.
I DO WANNA SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
ARE UNINCORPORATED.
AREAS OR CITIES.
HOW ARE FUNDS DISTRIBUTED TO THE
SERVERS WERE WITHOUT A DOUBT
THESE THEY FACE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS -- WITH THESE PROJECTS
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE WE WILL
WHEN THEY'RE PLAYING FOR SEA TO
SEA BUT ALSO ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE APPLYING TO THE M. P.
O.'S -- YEAH.
HOW HOW IS THIS DISTRIBUTED AND?
WHAT DO YOU RECOMMEND? THIRTY
ONE ON THE WAY YES I AM EIGHT I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE SO THERE'S THE
MPO COMPONENT WHICH IS THE TEN
LARGEST NPOS CAM -- HAVE THAT
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN COMPETITIVE
PROCESS AND SO I I THINK THAT
YEARS SPECIFICALLY ASKING ABOUT
THE UNINCORPORATED AREAS THAT
ARE WITH IN ONE OF THOSE LARGE
NPOS.
SO ANY ANY ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
CAN.
SUBMIT THROUGH THE STATE WIDE
PROCESS SO THEY HAVE A FIRST
CHANCE THAT THEY CAN GET FUNDED
OUT OF THE STATE WIDE PROCESS.
IN ANY ANY PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE HAVE THE FIRST CHANCE
THERE AND THEN THEY EITHER
COMPETE IN THE SMALLER BUT IN
RURAL COMPONENT OR THE MPO
COMPONENT.
SO THEN THEY CAN ALSO GET FUNDED
THROUGH OUT OF THE THROUGH THE
MPO COMPONENT.
DO YOU FIND THAT THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS -- IT
[inaudible]
THERE THERE.
THEY'RE BEING COMPETITIVE IN
THEIR APPLICATIONS.
WE'RE FOR IT IN MY AREA MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE TWO ONE
INCORPORATED AREAS.
THAT -- FROM WHAT I SEE GET
OVERLOOKED.
AND IS IT WOULD MAKE THE COUNTY
IS LOOKING FOR ALL OF THE CITIES
AND THEY DON'T ZERO IN ON THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS WHERE'S THE
CITIES.
THEY WERE GOING TO ZERO IN ON
THE CITIES AND THEY HAVE
ACCOUNTED BACK THEN AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- THE STATE WIDE
COMPONENT -- IT OFFERS THE
ABILITY FOR AN UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITY TO APPLY. FOR FUNDING
TO THE STATE Y. COMPONENT AND
THE COMMISSION HAS FUNDED A I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE ACTOR
TRANSPORTATION RESOURCE CENTER.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THAT -- IS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
ANYONE THAT IS INTERESTED IN
THAT ASSISTANCE BUT REALLY ONE
OF THE PRIMARY FOCUS IS A IS A
OF THOSE AND INCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE -- YOU
KNOW THE WRITING APPLICATIONS
MAYBE FOR THE FIRST TIME WE ALSO
HAVE.
THIS LAST CYCLE BASED ON
FEEDBACK AND HAVE MODIFIED THE
APPLICATION -- FOR REQUIREMENTS
SO THAT NOW WE HAVE MULTIPLE
APPLICATIONS DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE OF THE PROJECT BECAUSE IN
THE UNINCORPORATED AREAS.
A TEAM THOSE PROJECTS TEND TO BE
THE LOWER DOLLAR VALUES SMALLER
PROJECTS AND NOW THEY NEED TO A
THEIR APPLICATION LESS
INFORMATION.
IT'S A WERE WORKING -- TO TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THE
UNINCORPORATED AND THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES.
SO THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO BE
COMPETITIVE IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMISSION.
AND SO THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JOHN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE WITH YOU MIGHT
INTRODUCING YOURSELF I DON'T
BELIEVE YOU DID WHEN YOU.
YES AS SUSAN BRANSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION IN EARLIER MISTER
PARENTS ARE WATERS AFTER
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM MANAGER
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU OF GLAD TO HAVE BOTH
OF YOU HERE -- AND I THINK -- BY
WITH THAT WILL DIFFER -- PUBLIC
INPUT UNTIL AFTER ISSUE TO
CENSOR THIS IS INFORMATIONAL
ONLY AND THAT'S GONNA BE A HOLD
OPEN ITEM -- SO FOR THOSE IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS -- ISSUE
PLEASE -- JUST WAIT A MOMENT
UNTIL WE'RE DONE WITH THE NEXT
PRESENTATION WHICH WILL BE --
ISSUE TO TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
OVERSIGHT.
THIS PRESS OKAY THANK YOU AND I
WILL HAVE WITH ME POPULOUS IS
KEY -- THE COMMISSION'S DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
AND MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
THE PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL ONE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE INCREASED
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING BY MORE
THAN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
THIS SB ONE HAS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE WORK
OF THE COMMISSION.
IT HAS A SIGN TO RESPONSIBILITY
TO THE COMMISSION FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
WITH RESPECT TO ADMINISTRATION
AND OVERSIGHT OF THESE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS.
IT'S INCREASE THE ADMINISTRATION
OF SEVERAL NEW PROGRAMS AND
AUGMENTED EXISTING PROGRAMS.
IT IS ALSO INCREASE THE
COMMISSION'S OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR HOLDING
CALTRANS AND LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
EFFICIENT.
INVESTMENT OF PUBLIC FUNDS.
THE COMMISSION UNDERSTANDS AND
APPRECIATES THE RESPONSIBILITY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
INTERESTED IN IT WITH RESPECT TO
SENATE BILL ONE AND HAS WORKED
HARD OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS TO
ADOPT PROGRAM GUIDELINES. TO
ULTIMATELY THAT HAS -- TO COMMIT
FUNDS TO PROJECTS AND ALLOCATE
FUNDS TO TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THE COMMISSION HAS PERFORMED
THIS WORK IN A VERY OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT PUBLIC MANNER.
IS HELD OVER FORTY PUBLIC
WORKSHOPS IN ADDITION TO ITS
REGULAR OF BUSINESS MEETINGS. TO
DEVELOP THE GUIDELINES THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO DEDICATION OF
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE AND FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
THE COMMISSION HAS ADOPTED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
GUIDELINES WITH VERY SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS TO HOLD CALTRANS.
REGIONAL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE DELIVERING
ON THE PRESS BUT THE PROMISES
THAT WERE MADE.
INCLUDING EXTENSIVE MONITORING
AND REPORTING.
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
COMPLETING ITS WORKLOAD THROUGH
THE RE DIRECTION OF RESOURCES
RETIRED ANNUITANTS STUDENT
ASSISTANCE AN INCREASED LEVEL OF
OVERTIME BY ITS EXISTING STAFF.
THEREFORE THE COMMISSION IS
REQUESTING AN INCREASE IN ITS
BUDGET AUTHORITY FOR THREE
PERMANENT POSITIONS.
IN A LIMITED TERM POSITIONS AS
WELL AS THE REALLOCATION OF
FUNDING SOURCES WITHIN ITS
CURRENT BUDGET AUTHORITY.
THE REQUESTED POSITIONS WILL
ADDRESS INCREASED WORKLOAD AND
SEVEN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
ONE POSITION WILL BE ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
SUSTAINABILITY ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND OTHER RELATED
ISSUES THE CROSS OVER ALL OF THE
COMMISSION'S PROGRAMS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION
I RESPECTFULLY SEEK YOUR
APPROVAL OF THIS REQUEST SO THAT
THE COMMISSION IS ABLE TO HIRE
THE STAFF IT NEEDS TO
EFFECTIVELY CARRY OUT ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
GREAT ANY QUESTIONS.
MS REST.
WHEN WILL THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW LIKELY BE COMPLETED?
I WOULD DEFER TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
JAMES MORE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DON'T HAVE A STRICT DUE DATE
ON THE MISSION BASED REVIEW
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
PROCESS BECAUSE THIS IS A
HOLISTIC VIEW OF COMMISSION
STATUTORY MANDATES THE PROCESSES
HOUSE BE ONE IS GOING.
TO AFFECT THEIR PROCESSES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT PUTTING OURSELVES IN A
POSITION WHERE WE HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN SUBMITTING AND ON OUR
OUR OWN SAID DUE DATE OR DOING
THE THOROUGH REVIEW.
THAT BEING SAID BECAUSE THESE
EIGHT POSITIONS ARE REQUESTED ON
A TEMPORARY BASIS THE GOAL IS
CERTAINLY.
TO HAVE THE REVIEW BE COMPLETED
BEFORE THAT TIME SO THAT ANY
FUTURE REQUESTS TO EXTEND TO
SOME OR ALL OF THOSE POSITIONS.
IS INFORMED BY THE THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT WE GAIN FROM COMPLETING
THEIR VIEW.
SO.
HOW MANY OF THE COST BEING
REQUESTED -- BEING CURRENTLY
REVIEW -- THE REVIEW IS GOING TO
LOOK AT THE COMMISSION ENTIRELY
NOT IT'S NOT GONNA BE LIMITED TO
THESE ELEVEN POSITIONS IT'S
GONNA WORK AT THE COMMISSION IN
ITS ENTIRETY BUT IT'S INCLUDING
THESE POSITIONS.
IT'S GOING -- TO IF I UNDERSTAND
THE QUESTION I THINK THAT IT'S
GOING TO INCLUDE EVERYTHING
INCLUDING THESE POSITIONS ALL
THE PROGRAMS THAT CDC OVERSEAS
AND HOW YOU KNOW.
THERE WAS A THEM THREE THE
POSITIONS ARE PERMANENT THE
OTHERS ARE TEMPORARY.
CORRECT IF THAT'S CORRECT OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER.
YOU'RE WELCOME -- MISS PATTERSON
DID YOU HAVE A JUST A BUT THAT
IS KIND OF OFF SUBJECT.
I DO THAT ON A YOU COULD DO THAT
NOW OR WAIT THE END OF THE
PRESENTATION -- WHAT'S YOUR
CHOICE -- YOU PREFERENCE IF IT'S
SUB LIKELY OFF TOPIC I THINK I'D
RATHER ALLOW THE GERMAN TATIAN
AT EIGHT AND THEN.
AT THE END GREAT THANK YOU --
AND SO -- DID YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT -- YOU
WANT TO MAKE ON BEHALF OF
FINANCE.
NOT ON THIS ITEM HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT NOTHING HAD YOU
BEEN ABLE TO COMPLETE TO I HAVE
THANK YOU OKAY -- EN LA UP.
SURE JUST AYE ECHOING THE THE
COMMENTS AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SO SB ONE DID
DEFINITELY INCREASE THE
COMMISSION'S WORKLOAD AND
THERE'S A LOT MORE MONEY THAT
THE COMMISSION IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALLOCATING.
IT ALSO INCREASE THE
COMMISSION'S WORKLOAD IN TERMS
OF CREATING AS SORT OF A HIGHER.
LEVEL OF STANDARD FOR PROJECT
LEVEL OVERSIGHT WHICH WAS
SOMETHING OUR OFFICE HAD A LONG
RECOMMENDED AS AN APPROPRIATE
ROLE FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND IN RECOMMENDING
THAT IN THE PAST WE CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT WOULD TAKE.
ON POTENTIALLY CONSIDERABLE
ADDITIONAL ON STAFF RESOURCES
FOR THAT THE CTC TO DO THAT AND
I JUST POINT OUT THAT YOUR STOPS
AGENDA IT NOTES THAT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE EIGHT OF
THESE POSITIONS ARE LIMITED TERM
BUT THE WORKLOAD IS ON GOING
THAT IS THAT IS CORRECT THIS IS
ONGOING WORKLOAD IT'S NOT
TEMPORARY WORKLOAD -- WITH THAT
SAID WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WITH ADDING RESOURCES
TO THE COMMISSION IS THAT -- IS
SOMETHING THAT WE RECOGNIZED IN
THE PAST WOULD BE NEEDED.
ALL RIGHT -- MISS PATTERSON.
VERY QUICKLY.
HOW WE -- NINETY NINE COULD YOU
GET TO ME.
ANY PLANS OR CRIME LINES WITH
RESPECT TO GETTING ADDITIONAL
LANES NORTHBOUND AND SOUTHBOUND
ON HIGHWAY NINETY NINE FROM
SACRAMENTO -- TO BAKERSFIELD
OBVIOUSLY NINETY NINE IS A MAJOR
TRANSPORTATION CORNER MAJOR
GOODS MOVING CORD OR WHEN YOU'RE.
THREE LANES NORTH AND THREE LANE
SOUTH IT'S SAFER IT GOES -- TO
WHAT DID THAT THE TRAFFIC IS IS
RUNNING AT A GOOD A GOOD PACE.
WHEN IT GOES DOWN TO THE TO
LANCE THIS IS WHEN THINGS CLOG
UP AND WHEN WE GET SOME
ACCIDENTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT?
I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF GOING
FORWARD THERE'S PROGRESS ON
NORTH BOUND IN SOUTH SOUTH BOUND
LANE ADDITIONS.
THANK YOU I WILL MAKE A TWENTY
SHOULD BE THERE OFFICE VERY MUCH
THANKS.
SURE REFER FONG WELL LET ME JUST --
ACOSTA NEW -- MISTER PATTERSON
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH LANE
EXPANSIONS BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU
WISH.
FOR OTHERS THAT COULD YOU JUST
EGGMAN AND A GOOD YOU INCLUDE ME
AND THAT THE INFORMATION
CERTAINLY OKAY LET'S SCHEDULE
OPEN.
YOU'RE WELCOME -- IF THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THEN --
WHEN WE SEE IF THERE'S ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUES ONE AND
[inaudible]
TWO PLEASE [inaudible]
YEP.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JONATHAN AMOUNTS I REPRESENT
THE SAFE WHICH THE SCHOOL.
SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL NATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP ARE JUST A QUICK
CALL SOME QUICK COMMENTS ON THE
ELLIE A REPORT ON THE TEE PEE
WEE -- WERE -- STAKEHOLDER
INVOLVED IN THE CREATION OF THE
PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN -- ON THE
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WERE WE CONSIDER THE ATP COURT --
TO OUR OUR MISSION AND JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT A FEW THINGS THAT --
WE THOUGHT COULD HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT AND ALSO
WANTED -- TO CLARIFY OUR OUR
SENSE OF OF SOME OF THE FINDINGS
AS WELL -- GENERALLY SPEAKING --
WE ARE WE THINK THAT THE BY FAR
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE FACING
PROGRAM IS THE HUGE GAP BETWEEN
THE FUNDS AVAILABLE AND THE
FUNDS REQUESTED.
CURRENTLY RIGHT AROUND -- 19%
RIGHT NOW IT'S THAT'S KIND OF AN
ONGOING A SORT OF META ISSUE
WHICH WE THINK SORT OF HIS AS AT
THE ROOT OF MANY OF THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS --
FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE PROGRAM --
WE ALSO THINK THE PROGRAM IS TO
BE COMMENDED ON THE THE GREAT
SUCCESS THAT IS HAS WE REALLY
SEE IT AS A MODEL PROGRAM IN
TERMS OF STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT.
IN TERMS OF VALUING A PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION -- AND IT JUST IN
THE LAST -- GUIDELINES -- CYCLE --
THE RIGHT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN
AND FIFTEEN WORKSHOPS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE ON THE AND ON
PRESIDENT NUMBER STAKEHOLDERS
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE INPUT INTO
THE BEST SCORING.
ON THE END RESULTS IN MORE THAN
A HUNDRED PROFESSIONALS ACROSS
THE STATE -- DEDICATING.
AROUND THIRTY HOURS OF THEIR
TIME MY SELF INCLUDED TO TO
EVALUATING APPLICATIONS SO WE
THINK THE PROGRAM IS TO BE
COMMENDED FOR A TRADING AS THEY
Y. CONSTITUENCY ACROSS THE STATE
AND ON WE'VE CERTAINLY HAD OUR
OUR ISSUES IN THE EVALUATION
PROCESS BUT WE DON'T WANT TO IN
ANY.
WAY DUPLICATIVE ON THE RATHER WE
WE FIND IT'S A WAY TO FOR
EXAMPLE MAKE SURE THAT PROJECTS
THAT DEMONSTRATE -- EXCEPTIONAL
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION RISE TO THE
TOP JUST SPEAKING OUT FROM MY
OWN EXPERIENCES EVALUATOR THAT
REALLY YOU I WAS ABLE TO SHINE
THROUGH AN APPLICATION FROM
PLACES LIKE -- KERN COUNTY --
WERE SIMPLY A TERRIFIC PROJECTS
WHICH MAY NOT HAVE FIT A
TRADITIONAL DEFINITIONS OF
TRANSFORMATIVE IN TERMS OF LARGE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS -- BUT BECAUSE OF
THE RELATIVELY SMALL COMMUNITIES
FIRST A PRICE TAG AROUND SIX OR
SEVEN MILLION JUST CREATING YOU
KNOW SOME SOME PROTECTED
SIDEWALKS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
REALLY HAS THE POTENTIAL TO TO
GREATLY TRANSFORM THAT COMMUNITY
AND SO WELL WE WILL BE HAS
ATTENTION.
AND A CAUTIONARY ABOUT --
INSTITUTING GUIDELINES THAT
PUSHED FOR LARGER AND LARGER
PRICE TAGS AND DEEMING ONLY
THOSE PROJECTS TRANSFORMATIVE --
GOING FORWARD -- SO I BELIEVE
THAT IS THE EXTENT OF A COMMON
SET I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
A I TWO ITEMS ON THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS MORNING
WE WILL MOVE ON NOW -- TO
CALTRANS ISSUES THREE THROUGH.
FIVE WE DO HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROVE -- ISSUE THREE AND
THEN THAT TO HOLD OPEN ON
FOREIGN FIVE SO WE'LL HEAR
PUBLIC COMMENT -- AFTER ISSUE
THREE AND THEN AGAIN AFTER ISSUE.
FIVE GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME.
IN THE MORNING.
MORNING I'M LAURIE BERMAN I'M
THE CALTRANS DIRECTOR WITH ME IS
CLARK CALL CENTER.
DIVISION CHIEF FOR BUDGET. TO GO
AHEAD AND START YES PLEASE OKAY --
WILL START WITH THE ROAD REPAIR
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OCT
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN B. C. P. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION OR
CALTRANS REQUEST TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE OPERATIONS.
LOCAL ASSISTANCE AND CAPITAL
OUTLAY FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
UNDER THE ROAD REPAIRS
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS SB.
ONE THIS REQUEST IS FOR ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
ACCOUNT OR R. M. ARE A FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT FUNDING LEVELS
ARE CONSISTENT WITH ANTICIPATED
SB ONE REVENUES.
CREATED FOR THOSE USES ARE IN
THERE ARE A APPROPRIATIONS TO
EXPAND.
SB ONE FUNDING ALSO INCLUDE
INCLUDED IN THE STATE TRANSIT
ASSISTANCE BUDGET THE SECRETARY
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY BUDGET.
AND THE SHARED REVENUE BUDGET.
SB ONE PROVIDE STABLE ON GOING
FUNDING FOR STATE HIGHWAY LOCAL
ROADS MAINTENANCE AND REPAIRS AS
WELL AS MATCHING FUNDS. FOR
LOCAL PARTNERSHIP PROJECTS
TRANSIT INNER INTERCITY RAIL
ALSO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THROUGH SB ONE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
FUNDING FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
THIS REQUEST SEEKS TO CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTATION CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEGISLATION.
THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
HIGHLIGHTS EXPENDITURES IN THE
CAL TRANS BUDGET FROM THE ARMORY
RESOURCES WHICH PRIMARILY FUND.
HIGHWAY MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION THIS SUPPORT
REQUEST INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF
TWENTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
AN ON GOING RESOURCES AND TWENTY
SIX POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
TOTALING FIFTY FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY THIS REQUEST
IS AN INCREASE IN POSITION OF
AUTHORITY FOR THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE MAINTENANCE AND
THIRTEEN EQUIPMENT PROGRAM
POSITIONS AS WELL AS A TWO YEAR.
IS TO TO YOUR POSITIONS FOR
EQUIPMENT ENGINEERING WORK.
THANK YOU THE LA -- OR
DEPARTMENT PLANTS.
NO PRESENTATIONS AND SO -- ANY
QUESTIONS IS THERE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE.
THREE SEEING NONE OF WE HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE IS
THERE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON [inaudible]
REYES REAVIS.
LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE.
FOR THE AREA PROJECT INITIATION
DOCUMENT.
CALTRANS REQUEST RESOURCES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BIENNIAL
ZERO BASED BUDGET PROCESS FOR
THE PROJECT INITIATION DOCUMENT
OR PYD PROGRAM IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES A TOTAL OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN POSITIONS.
FORTY TO FIVE FULL TIME OF
EQUIVALENTS FOR ARCHITECTURE AND
ENGINEERING OR A ANY CONTRACTING
AND CASH OVERTIME EXPENSES
TOTALING. EIGHTY FIVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION TO DEVELOP PROJECT
INITIATION DOCUMENTS THIS
REQUEST MAINTAINS CURRENT STATE
STAFFING LEVELS AND REFLECTS A
5% INCREASE. FORTY FIVE FOUR
POINT NINE MILLION IN STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT RESOURCES FOR
ARCHITECTURE AND ENGINEERING
CONTRACTING CAPACITY.
THIS WILL INCREASE THE A IN THE
AUTHORITY FROM 5% 210% OF THE
TOTAL.
HIT PROGRAM BUDGET.
CALTRANS BEGAN USING A ANY
RESOURCES FOR THE PIPP PROGRAM
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AT THE
TIME WHEN SB ONE WORKLOADS
STARTED THESE RESOURCES HAVE
PROVIDED THE PROGRAM NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY.
SPECIFICALLY THE INCREASE WILL
ALLOW THE PIPP PROGRAM TO
EXPEDITIOUSLY BRING ON
EXPERIENCED CONSULTANTS TO ALLOW
KIDS FOR THE MORE COMPLEX MULTI
OBJECTIVE PROJECTS HOPING TO
ACHIEVE THE PROJECT PERFORMANCE
TARGETS IDENTIFIED.
IN THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THANK YOU ANY -- COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
BUT SIR COVER ISSUE FIVE AND
THEN.
AND WE'RE GONNA I DO PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER SHE FIVE GOOD
MORNING DAVID I'M NOT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AS PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THREE
PAY ALL OUTSTANDING LOANS FROM
SPECIAL FUNDS. TO THE GENERAL
FUND AND THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER
APPROACH OF PAYING OFF THE
STATE'S BUDGETARY THAT BUILDING
ADDITIONAL RESERVES AND PAYING
DOWN OTHER.
LIABILITIES.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL THE GENERAL
HUNDRED HE PAID THE OUTSTANDING
LOAN OF THE APPROXIMATELY IN
UNDER THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE TRANSPORTATION
DEBT SERVICE FUND.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWENTY
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE USED TO
BAIL THAT -- BOND AT SERVICE FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
THANK YOU -- ALEJO COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS.
MR FONG.
SO JUST SO I CAN UNDERSTAND THIS --
SO THE THE CUT UP MAYBE THAT
PART OF AND AS GOOD AS THIS SO
YOU'RE THE TRUCK WHAT FEES YOU
GONNA BE.
THAT WERE BEING USED TO PAY FOR
THESE LOANS ARE YOU GONNA PAY
THOSE OFF.
CORRECT WITH WITH THE PAID UP
OFF EARLY CORRECT.
YES SO -- THAT THE PROPOSAL IS
TO TRANSFER THE REMAINING --
GENERAL FUND DEBT. TO THE
TRANSMISSION AT SERVICE FUND A
ONE YEAR BUT THEN WOULD HAPPEN
UNDER BUSINESS AS USUAL SCHEDULE
YES OKAY SO THEN WHAT HAPPENS.
TO THE TRUCK WAIT FEES AFTER THE
BONDS ARE PAID OFF.
SO THOSE WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
USED TO PAY OFF THE DEBT SERVICE.
BUT THE DEBT SERVICE WITH THE
LOANS ARE PAID OFF THERE WOULD
BE NO DEBT SERVICE THE GENERAL
FUND PORTION -- THE GENERAL FUND
THAT PORTION WOULD BE PAID OFF
BUT THE TRUCK WAIT THESE WOULD
CONTINUE BE USED TO PAY OFF THE
DEBT SERVICE ON THE ANNUAL BASIS.
SO HOW MUCH IS THAT.
AND ABOUT ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR MORE OR LESS.
POINT AND I CAN PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION YOUR
OFFICE IF YOU'D LIKE A MORE
EXACT ESTIMATES.
SO OKAY SO THEN YOU ARE.
YOU'RE PAYING OFF ONLY THE
GENERAL FUND PORTION OF THE OF
THE DEBT IS NOT THE FOR THAT
SERVICE.
CORRECT SO THAT THE STATE WOULD
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO PAY THAT
SERVICE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS THIS
PROPOSAL IS -- TO ACCELERATE THE
PAYMENT OF THE DEBT THAT IT WAS
ENCOURAGE -- INTO THE BUDGET.
AS OPPOSED TO SPENDING SPENDING
OVER TWO YEARS.
OKAY SO THEN AT SOME POINT THE
BONDS WILL BE PAID OFF.
COMPLETELY -- CORRECT AND I
BELIEVE THESE ARE THIRTY YEAR
BOND THAT HAVE TO GO BACK AND
CHECK SO IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG
TIME UNTIL THE CONCERT.
OKAY THEN SO BUT OVER TIME AS
THE DEBT SERVICE GET SMALLER.
THAN WHAT HAPPENS TO THE TRUCK
WE'D BE SO THEY STILL GO THROUGH
THEY STILL CONTINUE TO BE USED
FOR THE GENERAL FOR FRIGHTENS OF
JOHN FUND OR DO THEY GET AT SOME
POINT GET MOVED TO BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
SO.
HELLO STEVE WELCH PART IN A
FINANCE SO OVER TIME AS WAIT
FEES.
ARE AS DEBT SERVICE -- FOR
BECOME LESS THAN ONE THEN THE
AMOUNT THEY WERE COLLECTING
ANNUALLY WAIT FEES THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO
AMOUNTS WILL REMAIN IN THE WHO
TO AND BE DISTRIBUTED AS PART OF
THE LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS --
AND A STEP AND SHOP PROGRAM.
SO THE RIGHT NOW THE THERE THERE
IS A ALL OF THE WEIGHT FEES HAVE
TO GO TO COVERING BECAUSE
THERE'S MORE DEBT SERVICE THAN
THERE IS WAIT FEES.
BUT EVENTUALLY AS AS WE PAY OFF
DEBT.
SOMEWHERE IN THERE AND IN THE
VICINITY OF TWENTY THIRTY SIX
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN THAT THE
TOTAL THAT SERVICE WILL BE LESS
THAN THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF WEIGHT
FEES WE'VE COME TO COLLECT AND
AT THAT POINT.
THOSE WAIT FEES WILL THEN SEE
WHAT AND REMAIN IN THE IN THE
HOOD TO BE USED FOR US THE
SIMPLY DOT TRANSPORTATION
PURPOSES.
MR FUNG I CAN SEE -- THAT MISS
PETERS IS CHOMPING AT THE BIT TO
ADD A COMMENT HERE FEEL FREE.
TO JUST TO CLARIFY SO THAT THE
THE WEEK FEEL LOANS THAT ARE IN
AS PART OF THIS ITEM -- COMES
FROM WE WHEN THE STATE WAS IN
THE FISCAL CRISIS AND NEEDING
GENERAL FUND BUDGET SOLUTIONS
THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE WEIGHT
FEES THAT ONE BILLION ASH COMING
IN EACH YEAR WAS USED TO HELP
THE GENERAL FUND.
AND IT WAS DONE SO BY PRIMARILY
PAYING THAT THAT SERVICE ON
TRANSPORTATION MONTHS BUT AT THE
TIME IT WAS STARTED.
THE THE DEBT SERVICE I'M PRAYING
PRIMARILY ON I PROPOSITION ONE
BEAT WITH THE LAST THAN THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF WEIGHT FEES AND
SO THE BALANCE IN ORDER TO FULLY
BENEFIT FROM THE WEIGHT FEES WAS
LOAN TO THE GENERAL FUND.
SO THOSE ARE THE LOAN SO AND
THEN.
AS THE AMOUNT OF DEBT SERVICE
NOW HAS GROWN AND EXCEEDS THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE WEEK FEES
THOSE LOANS ARE REPAID TO
TRANSPORTATION TO PAY OFF THE
DEBT SERVICE AMOUNTS THAT ARE
HIGHER.
SO THAT BONDS ARE STILL BEING
REPAID ACCORDING TO THE SAME
FEEL LIKE THERE'S PLANNED THERE
SHOULD BE A FLOW CHART HERE.
SO SELFISH.
SO WALK ME THROUGH THIS ONE MORE
TIME SO THERE WAS SO IF YOU HAD
SAY A BILLION DOLLARS IN A WEEK
FEES COMING IN IN YEAR ONE AND
THAT THAT SERVICE THAT NEEDED TO
BE PAID IN THAT YOU'RE IN
TRANSPORTATION BONDS WAS. SIX
HUNDRED MILLION THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DIFFERENCE WAS A LOAN TO
THE GENERAL FUND AND NOT HAPPEN
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AS THE TOTAL
DEBT SERVICE ON TRANSPORTATION
BONDS WITH INCREASING A LOT OF
THE STATE SERVICES COMING FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND SIX PROP WHEN
BE BOND AND SO IT'S STILL.
INCREASING.
SO EACH YEAR THAT DIFFERENCE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ALONE TO THE
GENERAL FUND NOW THAT DEBT
SERVICE COSTS ARE MUCH HIGHER
THAN THE WEIGHT FEES.
AND SO THOSE FUNDS THAT WERE
LOAN TO THE GENERAL FUND COME
BACK TO THE TRANSPORTATION DEBT
SERVICE ACCOUNT TO PAY FOR THOSE
HIGHER DEBT SERVICE COSTS.
SO THE LOAN WAS NOT AT SERVICE
HIGHER.
IT GROWS OVER TIME AS THE BONDS
ARE SOLD SO -- PROPOSITION ONE
BE WAS A ROUGHLY TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR BOND AND SO THE STATE
STARTED SELLING THOSE BONDS AND
PROBABLY ABOUT.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN BUT STILL YOU
KNOW DON'T SELL THEM ALL AT ONCE
SOME OF THEM OVER YEARS AS
PROJECTS ARE ARE COMING ON LINE.
AND SO THOSE COSTS WOULD GROW
OVER TIME UNTIL THEY REACH THEIR
PEAK AND THEN EVENTUALLY TRAIL
OFF SO THEY STARTED WHEN THE
BOND COSTS ARE STILL RISING --
AND THAT'S WHERE THAT LITTLE
LOAN PEACE COMES FROM AND SO THE
PIECE.
ON YOUR AGENDA TODAY THE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
MILLION IT'S JUST THAT THE
REMAINING AMOUNT THAT HAVE BEEN
LOAN TO THE GENERAL FUND NOW
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
TRANSPORTATION THAT SERVICE FINE.
AND WILL BE AVAILABLE THIS YEAR
NEXT YEAR THE FUTURE YEARS TO
PAY OFF THOSE INCREASED DEBT
SERVICE COSTS.
SO WE'RE SO WE'RE PAYING OFF.
WHO WOULD BE THE WORK WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA A U. THIS
PROBE BEING PROPOSED AT EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVEN THREE MILLION
DOLLARS?
AND WAY FEES.
WILL BE NOW USED TO PAY DOWN THE
THE THE GENERAL FUND LOW.
THAT WILL PAY OFF ALL THE MONIES
THAT WENT TO THE GENERAL FUND --
TO BE USED IN THE GENERAL FUND
WHILE WE'RE SORT OF WAITING FOR
THOSE THAT SERVICE COSTS TO GET
HIGH ENOUGH TO USE THEM FOR
TRANSPORTATION BONDS OKAY SO
THEN NOW THE TRANSPORTATION DEBT
SERVICE COSTS.
ARE HIGH ENOUGH THAT THE FUNDS
CAN BE TRANSFERRED BACK.
BACK TO THE DEBT SERVICE FUND
AND WILL BE USED TO PAY DEBT
SERVICE COSTS THIRTY SENSUALLY
ALLOW IT ALLOW THE GENERAL FUND
TO FULLY BENEFIT FROM THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF THE WEEK FEES.
AND STILL ESSENTIALLY SET THAT
MONEY ASIDE TO PAY FOR THOSE
BOND BECAUSE EVEN WHEN THE BOND
COSTS WEREN'T.
QUITE HIGH ENOUGH TO FULLY USE
UP ALL THOSE.
AND THEN NOW IT'S BIGGER PIC.
OKAY THAT WAS A VERY COMPLICATED
ANSWER BUT OKAY SO AT THE END
BUT YOU'RE PAYING THIS THIS THIS
LOAN BACK EARLY.
RIGHT WHEN YOU'RE EARLY.
CORRECT -- IF THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF DEBT SERVICE THAT WE PROJECT --
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROXIMATELY OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN THE
THE THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF WEIGHT
FEES WE PLAN TO COLLECT THAT
YEAR.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED SEVENTY
SOMETHING MILLION DOLLARS INTO
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY IN THE BANK
SO -- DO IT WITHOUT THIS
LANGUAGE WITHOUT ANY OTHER US
STATUTORY CHANGE WE WOULD REPAY
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN AND THEN PAY THAT AMOUNT TO
THE TRANSPORTATION THAT SERVICE
ACCOUNT -- THE TOTAL PROJECTED
THAT FOR NEXT YEAR WOULD THEN
USE UP THE THE REMAINING AMOUNT
OF THAT MONEY.
SO BUT LOWER PRESENT TO DO HERE
IS IN ORDER TO GET ALL SPECIAL
FUND -- LOANS TO THE GENERAL
FUND OFF THE BOOKS AT THE SAME
TIME SO OUTSIDE OF
TRANSPORTATION AND WITHIN
TRANSPORTATION IS TO REPAY
EVERYTHING -- WE'RE GONNA THREE
PAY THAT MONEY THIS YEAR NEXT
ANYWAYS IF WE HAVE THE MONEY
THIS YEAR REPAY IT THIS YEAR AND
THEN AS THE BUYERS AT A SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE.
YOU'RE A LIMB YOU'RE TRYING TO
REDUCE ELIMINATE THE GENERAL
FUND LIABILITIES BUT THE THE
TRAFFIC AND THAT -- WAIT FEE
LIABILITIES STILL EXIST WEEK YOU
LIABILITIES CONTINUE TO AND SO
OVER TIME AS THOSE WITHIN
PROPOSE IS THAT IF THOSE AS
THOSE LOANS ARE PAID OFF AND THE
WEIGHT FEES WITH AND GO BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION AFTER THAT.
EVERYTHING IS PAID OFF IN.
TWENTY THIRTY SIX THREE TWENTY
THREE SEVEN AS WE MOVE FORWARD --
THERE'S THERE'S NO OTHER -- CALL
IN THE WEIGHT FEES THAN THE
TRANSITION THAT SERVICE SO AS
TRANSPORTATION A SERVICE GOES
DOWN IN THE LONG TERM THAN THOSE
WAIT HE'S A RIB WHO WOULD BE IT
WOULD NO LONGER BE USED FOR THAT
AND TO BE USED -- FOR OTHER
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES.
STATUTORILY REQUIRED
OKAY I UNDERSTAND SO.
SO WHY WOULD WE JUST PAY OFF
WITH A WITH A GOOD MEASURE
SHOULD BE OPENED AND PAYING OFF
THE TRUCK WAIT FEES THAT THAT
THAT WOULD OR THE LOANS.
THE LIABILITIES IN THE WEIGHT
FEES WITH ADDITIONAL FUNDS SO
THAT WE WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO
USE TRUCK WAVY MONEY SOONER
CORRECT TRANSPORTATION WILL
BEGIN THESE A LONG TERM -- DEBT
DEBT -- LIABILITIES FROM FROM
THE BOND SO -- YOU KNOW THERE'S
A PAYMENT SCHEDULE THEY HAVE YOU
KNOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN SOLD FOR
FOR MULTIPLE YEARS OF YOU KNOW
THE STATE'S Q. HAS A PORTFOLIO.
THAT THEY MANAGE -- FOR FOR ALL
OF THEIR DEBT SO YOU KNOW WE
MANAGE THAT FOR FULLY ON A YEAR
BY YEAR BASIS WE DON'T SELL
BONDS UNTIL PROJECTS ARE READY --
I GOT SO SO THAT THAT PORTFOLIOS
MANAGED THROUGH THE THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY GROUP AND THROUGH THE THE
STATE'S -- CASH MANAGEMENT.
AND YOU KNOW SO I THEY THEY
MANAGE THAT TO IT TOO IT'S
ESSENTIALLY PAY AS LITTLE
INTEREST AND GET AS MUCH
PRINCIPLES POSSIBLE A THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THAT'S PATTERSON.
CAN I I'D LIKE A LITTLE
CLARIFICATION ON THE USE OF
FUNDS. FOR FOR DEBT ENOUGH AT IT
SO IT'S BEEN COMPLICATED I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
HAVE TRUCK FEE.
WAIT WAIT FEES HAVE.
A GAS TAX FEES -- BEN UTILIZED.
TO PAY OFF THE PRINCIPAL AND
INTEREST.
ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL DEBT.
MY AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT'S A GENERAL OBLIGATION.
BOND IS THAT RIGHT AND ARE WE IN
SOME WAY.
EITHER MINGLING FUNDS OR IN SOME
WAY USING FEES. FOR ONE THING TO
PAY OFF SOMETHING ELSE
PROPOSITION ONE A IS A IS AN
ELIGIBLE USE FOR THE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION THAT SERVICE
COUNT SO THOSE THOSE FUNDS FOR A
A PORTION OF PROPOSITION ONE A
DEBT.
IS IS PART OF THAT EQUATION YES.
SO THERE'S PROP ONE BE PROP ONE
A PROPOSITION ONE NINETY TWO AND
PROPOSITION ONE AWAIT.
ARE ALL ELIGIBLE.
STATUTORILY TO BE PAID -- TO
HAVE THEIR INTEREST PAID OUT OF
THE TRANCE FISH THAT SERVICE
ACCOUNT.
IS YOUR ANSWER NO THAT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL BONDS ARE USERS YES
YES THOSE ARE AN ELIGIBLE USE
FOR SUCH FOR THE ELDERLY. TO
HAVE GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND
BEING PAID OFF WITH FEES AND
TAXES.
WE HAVE WAIT FEES BEING USED TO
PAY OFF TO BEING BEING TRANSFER
THE TRANSITION THAT SERVICE
ACCOUNT FOR THOSE FOR SPECIFIC
BONDS.
THANK YOU -- THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS LET'S MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON I FROM USE --
ISSUES [inaudible]
FOR FIVE ACCORDING.
THE WIZARD FAIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS STEVE BAKER
WITH THEIR NEW DISSOCIATES HERE.
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON ISSUE
FOR REGARDING PROJECT INITIATION
DOCUMENTS.
PEGS OPPOSED TO THE PORTION OF
THE PROPOSAL.
THAT WOULD DOUBLE THE AMOUNT OF
OUTSOURCING OF THE PIT DOCUMENTS --
WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT IT IS IT IS THE
INITIATION OF A NEW PROJECT WE
DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
CONTRACT OUT.
ANY OF THAT WORK -- IMAGINE IF
YOU'RE DOING IN ADDITION ON YOUR
HOUSE YOU'RE NOT GOING.
TO OUTSOURCE THE DECISION ON
WHETHER YOU NEED TO PUT AN
ADDITION ONTO YOUR OWN HOUSE.
YOU MIGHT OUTSOURCE -- SOME OF
THE DESIGN WORK LATER AFTER
YOU'VE MADE THAT DECISION BUT
THE SIZE OF A LANE WHERE IT'S
GOING.
THOSE ARE DECISIONS THAT.
GOVERNMENT IN CALTRANS WHO NEED
TO MAKE BASED ON THE TRAFFIC
SURVEYS IN THE INPUT THAT THEY
RECEIVE FROM THE LOCALS WE ALSO
NOTE THE PEG.
WENT ALONG LAST YEAR WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
OUTSOURCING IN GENERAL TO
ACCOMMODATE THE SB ONE DOLLARS.
NOW THAT THOSE MONIES ARE COMING
IN WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
REVERT BACK AND NOT OUTSOURCE
THOSE PROJECT INITIATION
DOCUMENT.
AND THEN FINALLY WE NOTE THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
COST OF OUTSOURCING THIS WORK A
COST OF AT LEAST DOUBLE THE COST
OF HAVING A STATE ENGINEER DO
THAT WORK.
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
KEEPING THIS ISSUE OPEN AND WE
HOPE THAT AS THE BUDGET GETS
CLOSED OUT.
THIS CAN BE RESOLVED IN A WAY SO
THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING THOSE
INCREASED COSTS THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARC WATTS
ON BEHALF OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA.
ORIGINALLY CAME HERE JUST -- TO
GENERALLY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
ON THE PADS -- IT'S GENERICALLY
I THINK A GOOD IDEA -- TO
MAINTAIN THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF FINANCING FOR THE PITS OVER
TIME CONSISTENT WITH A THE NEW
SP ONE ENHANCE PROGRAM.
SO WE WERE JUST GOING TO ENDORSE
HAPPEN I THINK I'D LIKE TO ADD
ON AFTER THAT COMMENTARY YOU
JUST HEARD THAT.
THERE'S ANOTHER GOOD REASON TO
LOOK AT A ANNIE CONTRACTING AT
THE SMALL AMOUNT OF INCREASE
OVER LIKE THAT.
OF ANOTHER 5% BECAUSE IT GIVES A
LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
DEPARTMENT IF WE CAN END UP WITH
SAVINGS.
IN THE PROGRAM OR WE END UP WITH --
A COMPLEX PROJECT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH BY
DIFFERENT DISTRICT.
THE ABILITY TO USE ANY
CONTRACTING IS -- PROVIDES THAT
MUCH MORE FLEXIBILITY SO JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THAT AS YOU PREPARE -- TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- IS BERMAN COULD YOU --
CLARIFY -- BASED ON THE A
COMMENT THAT WE HEARD.
WHAT THE INTENDED -- OUT EIGHT
USES FOR THE OUT SOURCING SURE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT'S
THE DECISION MAKING IS GOING TO
BE RETAINED THE DECISION A I'LL
BE RETAINED WITH CALTRANS THE
ENGINEERING THE DESIGN.
A LOT OF THAT WILL BE DONE BY
THE CONSULTANTS -- TYPICALLY WE
HAVE 10% ON THE CAPITAL SIDE
WERE ASKING FOR THE FLEXIBILITY
TO GO FROM 5210% ON THE PIT SIDE.
WITH THE SB ONE DOLLARS WE NEED --
TO CONTINUE.
TO PRODUCES PIDS -- AND THESE
ARE FLEXIBLE RESOURCES SO -- WE
CAN SHIP THEM MORE EASILY
BETWEEN DISTRICTS.
WE DON'T NEED IT ALL WE DON'T
HAVE IT ALL BUT IT ALLOWS US TO
CONTINUE TO RAMP UP.
ALL OF THE WORK AND DELIVER THE
SB ONE PROGRAM. ONE OTHER
COMMENT -- IN THE STRUCTURE OF
THE PAID WORK -- THE CONSULTANTS
TO A PORTION OF THE ANALYSIS AND
EVALUATION AS IT RELATES TO THE
COMPLETION OF THE PAD -- BUT THE
ENTIRE PAID IS NOT DONE BY THE
CONSULTANT -- CALTRANS STAFF --
ARE ULTIMATELY A STILL INVOLVED
IN -- THE COMPLETION AND
PRESENTATION OF THE PATH.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU -- WILL
HOLD THIS -- OPEN -- AS WELL AS
ISSUE FIVE TWO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO CONSIDER -- THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF OF OUTSOURCING -- IN
THE CONTEXT OF WHAT YOU'VE
PROPOSED.
IN THE WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES
OUR A CALTRANS OVERSIGHT FOR
TODAY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS -- NEXT UP WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. FOR ISSUES SIX AND
SEVEN ALSO -- ABOVE HOLD OPEN
ITEMS WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE CONCLUSION OF ISSUE.
SEVEN THANK.
GOOD MORNING YOU HAD A A FULL
DAY OF OF QUESTIONS YESTERDAY --
AND TO COME BACK -- TO LED TO
THE CAPITAL FOR A OF ARE AT A
TWO ISSUES HERE TODAY WILL START
WITH THE MOTOR VEHICLE --
ACCOUNT FUND CONDITION IF YOU
COULD TO OF PLEASE ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATTHEW MISKITO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
I'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND GIVE YOU
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT -- THE NBA IS
PRIMARILY FUNDED BY A VEHICLE
REGISTRATION FEES AND DRIVER'S
LICENSE APPLICATION FEES
RESULTING IN ABOUT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE -- THE
ACCOUNT PRIMARILY SUPPORT CH P.
AND DMV STATE OPERATIONS AND
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN EXPENDITURES
OF HIS PROPOSED TWO POINT THREE
BILLION FOR C. H. P. ONE POINT
THREE BILLION FOR DMV.
AND FOUR HUNDRED SEVEN MILLION
AND AIR BE ANOTHER CLASS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE TEN
ROUGHLY EIGHTY TO NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEES -- HAS BEEN
TRANSFERRED FROM THE NVA TO THE
GENERAL FUND EACH YEAR.
THESE ARE FEES ARE NOT DIRECTLY
RELATED TO TRANSPORTATION AND
GENERATED BY DOCUMENT SALES AND
OTHER SERVICES PROVIDED BY DMV.
AS SUCH THEY ARE NOT PROTECTED
BY ARTICLE NINETEEN OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION AND WERE
THEREFORE ELIGIBLE TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AS SEEN ON PAGE TWENTY NINE IN
THE AGENDA.
THE NBA WAS PROJECTED TO BECOME
INSOLVENT AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AS PART OF THE JANUARY TENTH --
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
IN ORDER TO KEEP THE ACCOUNT
SOLVENT AND FUND THE CURRENT BCP
APRIL ONE PC P. REQUESTS THE
MINISTRATION PROPOSES. TO ONE
SUSPEND THAT GENERAL FUND
TRANSFER I MENTION FOR FIVE
YEARS WHICH WILL ADD FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND
AVAILABLE CASH -- OVER THAT TIME
PERIOD [inaudible] TO DELAY.
OF THE REPAYMENT OF THE LOAN
REQUIRED BY SB EIGHTY FOUR
UNLESS THE SUBLIMINAL PENSION
PAYMENT -- STARTING IN CURRENT
YEAR WHICH WILL ADD THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN AVAILABLE CASH -- FOR FIVE
YEARS. THREE WILL SHIFT THE CHP
OFFICE REPLACEMENTS TO THE
PUBLIC BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
FUND.
AND SUSPEND FIVE CHP OFFICE
REPLACEMENTS FIVE DMV OFFICE
PROJECTS AND BOTH DEPARTMENTS
STATEWIDE PLANNING AND CITED
INVOCATION EFFORTS.
THESE IF THE EFFORTS WILL KEEP
THE FUND SOLVENT WITH AT LEAST A
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR FUND BALANCE -- DROPPING
THAT FLOW TO DRIVE TO AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO THE
ADMINISTRATION GENERALLY
BELIEVES THAT.
A 5% RESERVE -- IS PRUDENT FOR
CASH FLOW PURPOSES -- THAT COMES
OUT TO ABOUT A ONE MONTH RESERVE --
REVENUES TO EXPENDITURES --
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO PROPERLY
BALANCE EXPENDITURES AGAINST
REVENUE -- 3% WAS CONSIDERED
ACCEPTABLE -- IN THE SHORT TERM.
GIVEN OUR APRIL ONE PROPOSALS --
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPLIED.
UPDATED EXPENDITURES WHICH YOU
SEE IN THE AGENDA.
BUT THE FUN CONDITION DOES NOT
INCLUDE UPDATED REVENUES.
THOSE WILL BE UPDATED AS PART OF
THE REVISION PROCESS.
THANK YOU SO -- WHAT DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION BASS SETS UP A
OPINION ON THAT A RESERVE A 5%
THAT -- EQUATES TO ONE MONTH THE
OF REVENUE IS.
APPROPRIATE OR BEST PRACTICE.
WELL HISTORICALLY THAT'S
GENERALLY WHAT WE ASSUME FOR
EVERY FUND -- BUT ESPECIALLY
THIS ONE WITH THIS MUCH.
REVENUE AND AS MANY EXPENDITURES
AS OCCUR -- I GUESS WHAT I'M
ASKING IS -- WHY IS THAT CONCERT
ACT ARE YOU STATING THAT THE --
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERS THAT
INTO THE THE BEST PRACTICE --
FOR A RESERVE AND IF SO.
WHAT IS THAT CONCLUSION BASED ON?
THAT -- A STANDARD AMONGST ALL
STATES -- AND WE'RE WE'RE SECOND.
FOR WELL IT AWAY MAN.
THE MAN ABOUT DEPARTMENT FINDS.
THAT IT'S JUST BEEN A HISTORIC
LEVEL -- ACROSS SPECIAL FUNDS
HISTORICALLY 5% RESERVE WAS
CONSIDER PUTTING A BURDEN
RESERVE.
TYPICALLY THAT OR KLAY OVER WHAT
PERIOD OF TIME I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET A AN IDEA WHETHER.
SINCE I'VE BEEN AT FINANCE
FIFTEEN YEARS THE WAY WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE I I'M AFRAID SO YES --
NOW.
HISTORICALLY THE DMV IN THE C.
H. P. WHO ARE THE PRIMARY USE OF
OF THE NBA HAVE MANAGED.
WHEN IT'S GOTTEN AS LOW AS A
HUNDRED MILLION?
BELOW THAT WE WOULD FOR NOT TO
GO AGAIN FOR CASH REASONS -- I
KNOW THE GENOCIDE IDEALLY WE SET
HUNDRED IDEALLY WE DON'T WANNA
GO BELOW THAT FOR CASH REASONS
BUT OF OF MORE PRUDENT RESERVE
WOULD BE ON THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR -- TWO HUNDRED TO
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
LEVEL SIMPLY FOR MANAGING THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S FLOWING
IN AND OUT PAYING SALARIES
ETCETERA.
OKAY SO THAT WOULD BE THE THE
GOLD TO A YOU THINK WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE -- AND WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US IS THAT KIND OF
PATCHWORK OF OF FIXES THAT ARE
RELATIVELY SHORT TERM IN NATURE
I THINK THE FOR UP TO FIVE YEARS.
YES THE V. I. V. IDEAS TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THE BAD.
THE REAL ID SPIKE WHICH IS WHICH
AND OUR PROPOSAL WOULD --
REQUIRE SOME.
I'M USUAL.
INCREASES IN EXPENDITURES AND SO
YES THIS IS TO BE ABLE TO OFFSET.
OFFSET THOSE IN THE SHORT TERM
THAT MAKES SENSE BUT WHAT --
OTHER THAN A REAL ID BEING
RESULTS THAT'S NOT REALLY A LONG
TERM FIX SO WHAT -- PROPOSALS
WOULD THE ADMINISTRATION BE
MAKING.
TO ADDRESS THIS ON A PERMANENT
PERMANENT OR LONG TERM BASIS.
WELL AS YOU CAN SEE NOTHING IN A
STATEMENT WE DO DROP DOWN BUT
THEN WE DO START TO GO BACK UP
AS YOU KNOW.
THE VARIOUS FEES HAVE CPI
INDEXED FOR INFLATION SO -- THEY
WOULD.
WHAT WE GO DOWN BUT THEN WE THAT
REVENUES KICK UP ENOUGH? TO HELP
BRING IT BACK UP OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS A FUND THAT WE ALL MONITOR
VERY CLOSELY.
I'M A WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
MONITOR REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES TO SEE IN THE
FUTURE YOU KNOW.
THREE FOUR YEARS OUT -- IF
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS ARE NEEDED
[inaudible]
SO -- WAIT AND SEE.
SOUNDS LIKE THE AT THE MOMENT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S I MEAN
BASED ON ON WHAT WE HAVE BEST
ESTIMATES RIGHT NOW WHAT THE
MINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED.
KEEP THE FUND SOLVENT.
IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED THE THAT IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE -- BY
MEMBERS -- THAT WE APPROPRIATE
TO CONSIDER EXPANDING THE NUMBER
OF CHP OFFICERS A IN THE STATE --
WHAT WOULD A PATHWAY BE -- OF
FOR PROVIDING FUNDING FOR THAT.
WELL I KNOW THERE WAS OF A BILL
LAST YEAR THAT WAS VETOED THAT
PROPOSED ADDING TWO HUNDRED
OFFICERS A YEAR UP TO SIX
HUNDRED WHICH WOULD HAVE
RESULTED IN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE MILLION ONGOING -- WHICH
ARE GIVEN THE CURRENT.
EXPENDITURES THE FINE COULD NOT
SUPPORT.
ROM SO AND I'M ASKING IF FOR A
THE ADMINISTRATION IS GIVEN SOME
CONSIDERATION -- TO
ACCOMMODATING THAT SINCE IT WAS
A BILL AND TO MAY BE UNDER
CONSIDERATION AGAIN THIS YEAR IN
THE FUTURE.
WE WOULD HAVE TO BALANCE THE
EXPENDITURES OUT OF THE NBA
ALTERNATIVE FUNDS SOURCES
REVENUE CHANGES IT WOULD BE A
QUITE A BROAD -- BRIDE DISPLAY
OF ITEMS THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
CONSIDER IN ORDER IF IF WE ARE
TO CONTINUE FUNDING -- INCREASED
OFFICERS OUT OF THE NBA OKAY
WELL -- THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM
AND SO WE CAN DO SOME
CONSIDERATION OF THAT QUESTION --
BETWEEN NOW AND THE NEXT TIME
THAT -- THE COMMITTEE OF
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE TO DO ONE
AT SOMETHING SURE ANTHONY SYMBOL
FROM THE LESSEE BALANCE OFFICE
JUST WANNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS.
THE FIRST IS IN TERMS OF THAT.
MAGNITUDE OF THE NEEDFOR
DIFFERENT ACTIONS TO ADDRESS
SORT OF THE CONDITION OF NVA
REALLY STARTS WITH THE LEDGES
PARTIES FOR EXPENDITURES DO YOU
PROVIDE THE SAME LEVEL OF
EXPENDITURE MAYBE AS A GOVERNOR
YOU MAY WANT.
TO PROVIDE A HIGHER.
LEVEL DEPENDING OTHER YOUR OTHER
PARTIES ARE YOU MAY WANT TO
PROVIDE A LESS LEVEL LOOK MUCH
OF THAT.
COVERS WAS FUNDING INCREASE FROM
EXPENSES FROM THE NBA DEALS WITH
SORT OF THE DMV DMV RELATED
ISSUES REGARDING THE WAIT TIME
NEVER PLACED REAL ID YOU MAY
DECIDE YOU DON'T WANT TO FULLY
FUND THOSE THERE.
THEN THEN THE ACTIONS NEEDED TO
KEEP THE FUND SOLVENT ARE ARE
THE SECOND THING I THOUGHT WAS
REALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF SORT OF
THE THIS ACCOUNT HAS BEEN HAVING
SOME ONGOING CHALLENGES
PERIODICALLY FOR LAST FOR MANY
YEARS SO YOU KINDA WANT TO THINK
SORT OF THE RIGHT OF THE
GOVERNOR POSES SO THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF SOME THESE PROPOSALS.
THE FIRST ONE I TALK ABOUT IS
THE GOV SUPPOSE OF SUSPEND THIS
TRANSFER FROM THE NBA TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
IT'S CURRENTLY ABOUT NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE USUALLY
DID IT THE LECTURE TOOK TOOK THE
INITIATIVE AND THAT IS IN. TWO
THOUSAND NINE TEN BECAUSE OF THE
STATE'S FISCAL CONDITION THESE
ARE FEES THAT ARE VERY AS
MISCELLANEOUS FEES THAT THAT THE
Vì COLLECTS THAT ARE RESTRICTED
BY THE CONSTITUTION UNLIKE THE
VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEES OR
DRIVER'S LICENSE FEES.
IN FACT LATER DID IT MICHELLE ON
A TEMPORARY BASIS WE NEED IS THE
DATA TRANSFER ON A ONE TIME
BASIS FOR ONE YEAR.
THEN BECAUSE OF HIS CONDITION WE
NEED FOR ANOTHER YEAR.
AND THEN PRIME MINISTRATION JUST
ASSUME IN THE BUDGET THAT IT WAS
JUST AS AUTOMATIC TRANSFER.
I'M GIVEN THE CONDITION OF ENVY
EIGHT GIVEN SOME OF THESE
ONGOING CHALLENGES A OF THE NBA
THAT IT WAS THIS INTENDED THESE
ARE TEMPORARY YOU MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER JUST.
A LIMITING THE TRANSFER ONGOING
BATES IS NOT JUST FOR FIVE YEARS
BECAUSE YOU KINDA WANT TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT'S THE CONDITION OF
THE FUND BEYOND ADMINISTRATION
FORECAST OF THE FIVE YEARS.
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE
ADDITIONAL COST PRICES WHETHER
IT'S INCREASE COSTS FOR C. H. P.
OFFICERS.
THE DEPARTMENT OR VEHICLES HAS
WANTS TO UNDERTAKE VERY IF IT
PROJECTS THOSE ARE GONNA ABOUT
YOUR COSTS BEYOND THE FIVE YEAR
PERIOD.
ON THE SECOND OPPOSE I JUST
WANTED TO COMMENT ON IS THIS
POSE THAT THE PART OF FINANCE
MANAGER REGARDING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS --
REGARDING A ALONE THAT WAS MADE
FROM THE STATE'S ON CASH BALANCE
TO THE CALPERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
THE MINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
SUSPEND ANY OF THOSE ANNUAL
PAYMENTS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
AS THEY MENTION A LARGE OF IT IS
A LOT A LARGE PART OF THEIR
PROPOSES TO SORT OF ACCOMMODATE
THE THING CHRIS COLFER RELAYED
THE THAT MAY MAKE SENSE BUT
YOU'RE REALLY PUSHING IN THE OUT
YEARS WERE THOSE PAYMENTS ARE
CAN BE MUCH HIGHER.
WERE REQUIRED TO MAKE THESE
PAYMENTS BY THE END OF BY JUNE
THIRTIETH -- TWENTY THIRTY AND
THERE'S GONNA BE ADDITIONAL
COSTS NOW YOU'RE SO ONE THING TO
THINK ABOUT IS.
YOU MAY WANT TO THINK ABOUT
ADJUSTING THE PAYMENTS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS MAYBE MAKING
LESS PAYMENTS THAN OTHERWISE
WOULD BEEN MADE AN INCREASING
SOMEBODY OUT YEARS RATHER THAN
JUST SUSPENDING THE MALL FOR THE
FIVE YEARS SO.
ARE VICE YOU IS THERE ARE SOME
THOUGHT THIS IS REGARDING THE
ACCOUNT BUT YOU WANT TO THINK
LONG TERM AND NOT JUST SORT OF
PATCH IT UP AND PUSH IT DOWN THE
LINE.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THAT
CONTEXT MR MULLIN DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION MIGHT AGES GET
ADDITIONAL REACTION FROM DO F.
TO WHAT.
YOU JUST HEARD [inaudible]
CERTAINLY -- IT OUT IN REGARDS
TO THE THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS --
IT COMES BACK TO WHAT LEVEL OF
RESERVE IS EVERYBODY COMFORTABLE
WITH -- LAST YEAR -- THERE WERE
SOME PROPOSALS THAT OUT.
TO FIND CAP SOME CAPITAL IT
ALLEY PROJECTS -- WITH THE A
PUBLIC BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
FUND AS WE HAVE THIS YEAR AND
THE DIRECTION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RECEIVE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AT THAT TIME WAS WE
DON'T WANT TO GO BELOW A HUNDRED
MILLION.
AND SO ACTIONS WERE TAKEN I
WOULD BELIEVE WE WOULD BE IN A
SIMILAR SITUATION HERE THAT --
IN IN OUR CURRENT CONDITION WE
GO TO ONE FIFTY FIVE IF THE
LEGISLATURE SAYS WE ARE
COMFORTABLE GOING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION WE WANT TO USE THAT
FIFTY FIVE MILLION.
TO CSUS YET PAY SOMETHING ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION -- THE
MINISTRATIONS OPEN TO
DISCUSSIONS OF WHAT THAT
COMFORTABLE LEVEL IS
[inaudible]
THIS VOTE.
I'D JUST A PIGGY BACK ON THAT
CERTAINLY A I THINK I SHARE THE
CONCERN OF A MISTER MULLIN
MISTER BLUE ABOUT TRYING TO BUT
BEING CONCERNED ABOUT.
DOING SOME BANDAID SAVINGS NOW
AND THEN BALLOONING THE COSTS IN
THE FUTURE.
ON THE ON THE SPECIFIC -- SHIFT
AWAY FROM A PAY AS YOU GO TO A
MORE LEASE BOND -- OPTION WOULD
THAT WITH THE LA -- AGREE THAT
THAT CONCERNS REMAINS TO THAT
WERE INSTEAD OF PAYING AS YOU GO
THE THE FIXING THINGS THAT IF WE
GO TO A BOND.
MECHANISM THAT WE PAY INTEREST
AND WE BLOOM THE COSTS IN THE
FUTURE.
YES BECAUSE I MEAN TRADITIONALLY
BOTH FOR DMV'S EACH PAY WE FIND
THE FACILITIES ON A PAY AS YOU
GO BASIS -- DOING BONTA
FINANCING ISN'T.
UNCOMMON IN WHATWE DO A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILDINGS BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT IT DOES SORT OF
PUSH THE PAYMENTS OUT AND DOES
INCREASE COST ON THOSE INTERESTS
THE OTHER THING ABOUT OF CITIES
I KNOW IT IS.
ROSS OF THE L<c.cyan>G IN PUSHING</c>
BACK A LOT OF PROJECTS THAT RIDE
IN FINDING THAT THE NEW DELAY
GINGER ADMINISTRATION HAD AGREED
TO PLAN AND OUR PERSON THOSE
BACK THOSE ARE ALSO GOING TO BE
COSTS IN THE OUT YEARS AS WELL.
SO YOU'RE RIGHT FINANCING ON
FINANCE BASES DOES INCREASE THE
INTEREST SAID THEN IT AT THAT
POINT -- WE RISKING.
TRYING TO KEEP IT SOLVENT NOW
AND THEN MAKING IT INSOLVENT
LATER.
LOUISE PUSH WHICH IS PUSHING
THAT WORK WHAT IS PUSHING IT OUT
RIGHT WITH OUR PROBLEMS ARE
REALLY FIX THEY WERE JUST.
WHICH WE WHAT WE'VE SORT OF BEEN
DOING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
SO ARE THERE BUT THE FROM THE LA
A PERSPECTIVE THAT ARE THERE
MORE -- STRUCTURAL CHANGES THAT
SHOULD BE MADE TO TO TO TO THE
NBA THAT.
THAT MAKES IT MORE SOLVENT AND
ARE THERE ARE THINGS THAT NOT
BEING CONSIDERED HERE -- THE
MORE LUXURY WE WE THOUGHT ABOUT
HAVING EXPLORED MUCH IN DETAIL
BESIDES THE STUFF THAT'S BEEN
FOR NOW ABOUT SORT OF INCREASING
REVENUES SO FORTH IS.
TAKEN THE CLOSER LOOK AT SOME OF
THE OTHER EXPENDITURES FROM THE
NBA IN ADDITION THE AMBIANCE IS
P. WE GIVE MONEY TO AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
FORD TO MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL
EFFECTS FROM VEHICLE EMISSIONS
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT THERE COULD
BE SOME OTHER FUN SOURCES THAT
THEY ARE BE HAS THAT THOSE COULD
BE FUNDED FOR I KNOW THEY HAVE
SOME SPECIAL FUNDS AT THAT ALSO
HAVE SOME.
ISSUESAS WELL BUT THERE COULD
BE SOME THAT.
ME MAYBE TO FIND AN ALTERNATE
FUNDING SOURCE THAT WOULD FREE
UP MOTOR VEHICLE OUT FUNDS THAT
COULD FIND OTHER EXPENDITURES SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WE COULD LOOK
INTO MORE.
FORTY OKAY THIS DOES BY A
FINANCE HAVE A RESPONSE OR AT
THE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION IN
REGARDS TO THIS.
SURE THANK YOU FAMILY MEMBER
FONG RANDY CATS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- THE PUBLIC BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION FUND.
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT IT COSTS
MORE THAN CASTS ITS.
BUT WHEN YOU ADJUST FOR
INFLATION IT'S MAYBE ABOUT 20%
MORE -- HOWEVER IT DOES ALLOW
PROJECTS ON A MANY AND ALL
TENDER BEING SUSPENDED WERE
CONSIDERED CRITICAL OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
ALLOW THEM TO BE COMPLETED IN A
MORE TIMELY MANNER HANNAH CASH
CONSTRAINED ENVIRONMENT -- WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THIS IS A VERY
COMMON APPROACH STATEWIDE A
CURRENTLY THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX ACTIVE PROJECTS --
STATEWIDE THAT UTILIZE THE
PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION FUND --
FAMILY ALSO NOTE THAT.
A WALL IT HAVE ON THAT THERE'S
BEEN OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT
UTILIZE IT THAT HISTORICALLY --
HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH FOR EXAMPLE
DOES THE MILITARY INSTALLED AT
HEADQUARTERS PROJECT WHICH IS
THE FIRST TIME MILITARY UTILIZED
A PUBLIC BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
FUND THEN ALSO THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONSOLIDATION PROJECT.
IS ALREADY -- A A PROJECT FOR
WHICH THE AND VA WOULD BE PAYING
SOME THAT SERVICE.
BUT A IN TERMS OF THE BUT YOU
AYE AYE I GUESS MY MY BROADER
POINT I GUESS OF TRYING TO GET
THE PERSPECTIVE ON THE PART OF
FINANCES.
DO YOU SHARE THAT THE CONCERNED
THAT WE ARE BASICALLY.
BALLOONING COSTS IN THE FUTURE.
AND FOR A SHORT TERM SAVINGS.
YOU DISAGREED YOU DISAGREE WITH
THAT ASSESSMENT OR DO YOU TO YOU
HAVE YOU SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS
BUT YOU JUST.
I THINK A LOT OF OF THAT I THINK
A LOT OF IT AND I'M JUST
SPEAKING ON THE CAP OUT LIKE.
I'M SORRY AND I'M JUST SPEAKING
ON THE CAP OUT LATE PARTS -- IS
[inaudible]
THAT.
THERE IS SOME DID WHENEVER YOU
DO BOND FINANCING IT WILL COST
MORE BUT THE FLIP SIDE IS IF
THESE PROJECTS ARE STALLED FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS.
THE PROJECT STILL NEED TO BE
COMPLETED AND SO THERE'S GOING
TO BE TO INCREASE THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION IN THE OUT YEARS
VERSUS BEING ABLE TO START THE
PROJECTS NOW -- A LOT OF TIMES
THERE'S A DISCUSSION THAT IT'S
JUST LOOK AT THE STREET CASH
BASIS BUT A DOLLAR -- THAT
DOLLARS FIFTEEN OR TWENTY OR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS FROM NOW IS
NOT WORTH AS MUCH AS A A DOLLAR
TODAY.
OKAY SO YOU AND I I THINK IN THE
BROADER POINT IS IT'S NOT JUST
THE THE THE LEAST BONDS IT'S
IT'S COMBINED WITH THE MADE WE
CAN LOOK AT THINGS THROUGH A
STRAW SO.
THAT IN ADDITION TO WHAT MR
MULLIN BROUGHT UP ABOUT THE THE
THE THE PENSION PAYMENTS
EVERYTHING ELSE SO.
HOLISTICALLY ME YOU MAY BE.
YOU KNOW YOU MADE SAVE A LITTLE
IN IN IN THE MIDDLE BUT THEN.
YOU KNOW TEN YEARS NOW WE NOW
WE'VE GOT INTEREST PAYMENTS THAT
WE GONNA DO ON THESE BONDS AND
THEN WE'VE GOT.
ADDITIONAL DEBT SERVICE ON ON
PENSIONS AND THEN WE REAP WE'RE
GONNA RELITIGATE WHAT WE DID THE
WHATEVER THE PREVIOUS ISSUE ON
THE TRUCK WAIT FEES WHERE YOU'RE
JUST GONNA BE MOVING MONEY
AROUND.
AND THE WHERE IT WENT AND WE
HAVEN'T MADE THE FUND ANYMORE
SOLVENTS SO I THINK THAT'S I
MEAN SO THAT'S I GUESS THE MY
GENERAL CONCERNED THAT I'M
TRYING TO GET YOU.
TO I'M TRYING TO TEASE OUT FROM
YOU IS THAT ARE THOSE IS THERE A
TEN YEAR PLAN INSTEAD OF MORE A
FIVE YEAR PLAN OR OR MAYBE WE'RE
JUST LOOKING AT THINGS FROM A
FIVE YEAR LEVEL.
I I'VE I WILL NOTE -- AGAIN
WHILE WE'RE DELAYING THE PENSION
PAYMENTS.
WE DO SEE THAT RESERVE BEGAN TO
GROW EVEN THOUGH IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR WERE MAKING A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT.
SO.
YOU KNOW IT.
THERE'S ALSO.
AM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WHAT REVENUES
MIGHT BE THEY MAY BE MUCH HIGHER --
I'LL ALSO NOTE THAT -- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS.
PROPOSED -- OF THIS YEAR A THREE
BILLION DOLLARS -- GENERAL FUND
PENSION PAYMENT -- TO CALPERS
AND THAT PAYMENT -- SAVES THE
NVA AN ESTIMATED SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION OVER OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS -- SO THE THOSE --
PAYMENTS THAT ARE NOT COMING OUT
OF THE NBA.
I WOULD JUST ADD ON WE WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE ADDRESSING A SHORT TERM AND
PUSHING SOME OF THESE OUT TO
LONG TERM THE IN THE LONG TERM
IT CAN'T IT CAN'T HANDLE IT BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TO MONITOR --
CLOSELY AND SEE WHAT AS YOU
NOTED YOUNG EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION COSTS ARE YOU THINK
THINGS THINGS DO CHANGE BUT
AGAIN EVEN IN THAT LAST YEAR THE
FUND CONDITION WHERE WE ADDED.
XIN BACK IN -- THE FUND BOUNCE A
STOCKBROKER RIGHT AND I CAN AND
I APPRECIATE THAT I I'M JUST
TRYING TO KIND OF GLEE MORE
INFORMATION AND AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
THREE BILLION DOLLAR DOWN
PAYMENT.
ATTHAT THAT MAKES SENSE TO ME
IT IT BUT THERE WERE WE'RE NOT
MAKING ANOTHER PAYMENT AND SO
WERE THE WERE LOW IN THE COST
AND ONE AND AND THEY WERE
INCREASING THE COST AND THE
OTHER BECAUSE WE'VE W'VE
STOPPED MAKING A PAYMENT ON
SOMETHING ELSE.
SO I THINK FROM FOR JUST AND AS
IT MYSELF AND I DON'T KNOW I WAS
THE FOR THE FULL COMMITTEE IS
THAT A MAYBE WE HAD A MORE
LONGER TERM -- PLAN -- IN
ADDITION TO EVERYTHING ELSE -- I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL SO
THANK YOU.
MS REST FALL BY MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S CLEAR
FROM THIS DISCUSSION THAT THERE
ARE STRUCTURAL DEFICITS HERE.
THAT WE'RE STILL PLEASE THERE
ARE SOME SERIOUS PROBLEMS -- I
APPRECIATED FROM THE ALEJO'S
COMMENTS ON PAGE.
THIRTY TWO OF TALKING ABOUT THE
TO EVALUATIONS THAT ARE BEING
THAT BEING UNDERTAKEN OUT OF
PARTNER FINANCING GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS.
AGENCY.
BUT ALSO TO CONSIDER DIRECTING
THE DEPARTMENT AGENCY TO SUBMIT
A REPORT.
AT SPRING BUDGET A POTENTIALLY
FISSION SEES.
IS THE DEPARTMENT PREPARED TO DO
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH THAT'S I WILL SPEK TO THAT
FROM A THE KATHY WHITE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF DMV SO WITH REGARDS.
TO PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS BUSINESS
RE ENGINEERING COST SAVINGS THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT DMV HAS
EMBRACED BUT I ALSO TELL YOU
THERE'S A LOT MORE OPPORTUNITY.
TO LOOK AT GAINING EFFICIENCIES
AND HOW WE RUN OUR OPERATIONS.
I WILL ALSO TELL YOU -- BASED ON
MY SHORT TENURE AT DMV --
THERE'S A LOT THAT WE DO THIS
VERY MANUALLY ORIENTED THAT IF
WE ACTUALLY LEVERAGE BETTER
TECHNOLOGY.
AND LOOKED AT WAYS TO AUTOMATE
WHICH ACTUALLY GAIN A LOT OF
EFFICIENCIES THERE SO DMV IS
RIGHT -- AND WE CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES --
ACTION ACTIVITY THINGS THAT WE
CAN MEASURE FROM A KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATOR -- WHAT'S
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT BACK TO
OUR CUSTOMERS WHEN WE ACTUALLY
GAIN THOSE EFFICIENCIES CAN WE
PROCESS THINGS MORE QUICKLY THAN
WE CURRENTLY DO.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THERE HAS TO BE AN UP
FRONT INVESTMENT. TO ACHIEVE
THAT STATE TO THEN ALSO GAIN THE
EFFICIENCIES SO I THINK.
GOING BACK TO WHAT THE LA ALWAYS
TALKED ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I THINK THERE'S SOME
IMMEDIATE SHORT TERM NEEDS.
BUT I KNOW FROM A DMV STANDPOINT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
AGENCY WE ARE COMMITTED TO ALSO
LOOKING AT HOW THE DMV CAN
BETTER SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS IN A
MORE EFFICIENT.
AND EFFECTIVE WAY AND AND MORE
COST EFFECTIVE WAY AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT I AM FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW.
I ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
LEAN ACADEMY HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HI.
I BELIEVE IN PROCESS PREVENT ITS
EVERY FIBER OF HOW I GO INTO AN
ORGANIZATION OPERATE.
AND IF I AM ALLOWED TO DO THAT
DMV WE WILL BRING THAT TO DMV.
BUT IT WILL TAKE TIME WITH EVERY
PRODUCT LINE I NEED TO GO IN
THERE AND SEE WHERE THE
EFFICIENCIES ARE THAT WE CAN
GAIN FOR ALL OF THOSE PRODUCT
LINES.
YOU SAY IF YOU'RE ALLOWED.
TO IS THERE AN ISSUE ABOUT THAT
WELL I'M CURRENTLY IN AN ACTING
ROLE IN THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE AND
SO THAT THAT'S ALWAYS DEPENDENT
ON WHERE THE GOVERNOR WANTS TO
GO AS WELL AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO MAKE.
CORRECT.
I THINK THAT THE KNOWING THE DMV
HAS BEEN IN THE NEWS FOR SO LONG
I THINK THAT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE SOMETHING ALREADY.
IN PLACE.
IT'S JUST AS MR FUNG'S TALKED
ABOUT NOT JUST A FIVE YEAR PLAN
BUT A TEN YEAR PLAN.
THIS HAS TO BE PART OF A
DEPARTMENT WITH SUCH STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS.
IF WE CONTINUE THE WHERE WE'RE
GOING.
WITHOUT THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TALKED ABOUT.
WE CAN'T CONTINUE PERIOD.
SO -- IT.
I GUESS IT'S SORT OF SURPRISES
ME THAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE HERE
AND WE'RE THE NUMBERS ARE
LOOKING THE WAY THEY'RE LOOKING --
SO THAT TEN YEAR PLAN.
RATHER THAN A FIVE YEAR PLAN IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND I HOPE THAT SUCH A REPORT AS
WELL AS RECOMMENDED BY THE LA --
IS SOMETHING THAT WILL BE LOOKED
AT WILL BE PREPARED SO THAT WE
CAN.
AB -- SO WHEN WE EVALUATE WE
HAVE SOMETHING TO BASE IT ON AND
I THINK THAT THOSE OF YOU ON THE
INSIDE WOULD BETTER KNOW WHERE
THE EFFICIENCIES.
AND INEFFICIENCIES ARE AND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED.
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
DEFICITS THAT WE DO HAVE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES -- AGAIN.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON APPROPRIATE
USE OF FUNDS.
AND THE STRUCTURAL [inaudible]
DEFICIT.
IT REALLY CONCERNS ME THAT WE
HAVE A FUND THAT.
I SUPPOSE ORIGINALLY STARTED TO
FIND DMV.
AND C. H. P. AND YET WE HAVE.
LOADED UP ON THIS BOND A LOT OF
EXPENDITURES.
MY QUESTION IS WHAT WITH THIS
FUN LOOK LIKE IF WE ZEROED OUT
ALL OF THE OTHER.
USES OF THOSE PLANS EXCEPT FOR
THE PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE C. H. P. IN THE DMV.
AS NOTED IN A GENDER -- JUST
CURRENTLY THAT'S ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR WOULD WOULD
ELIMINATE THE SUPPORT FOR A R.
B. AND I BELIEVE IT'S SIX
THIRTEEN TO SIXTEEN OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS THAT RECEIVE SOME
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE.
WE GET WHAT DOES THAT DO WHAT
DOES THAT DO TO OTHERS WHAT YOU
TALK ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR RESERVES THAT DO THAT.
EASILY.
WHAT WHAT WOULD IF IF YOU'RE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONAL ME THAT'S USABLE
MONEY FOR THE C. H. P. N. DMV?
I WAS A DEMONSTRATION IS NOT
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE AND BE
FUNDING FROM THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD OR OTHER DEPARTMENTS BUT
IF.
IF YOU WERE TO DO DO YOU FIND
ALL OF THOSE OTHER DEPARTMENTS
FROM THE NBA THE BALANCE IN THE
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT WOULD GO UP
BY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR.
THE UNWILLINGNESS TO DO THAT.
LEADS TO THE INEVITABLE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE THAT WE
HAVE IN MY JUDGMENT.
AND I'LL TELL YOU WHERE I FEAR
THIS INEVITABLY LEADS
[inaudible]
MORE FEES.
ON REGISTRATION.
HIGHER FEES TO PEOPLE WHO USE
THE DMV.
AND SO THE THE DOUBLE THE LAST.
FOR THE FIRST RESORT FOR THE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE FIXES.
ALWAYS GOES BACK TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I JUST WANNA KNOW YOUR
OPINION OF WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS DOWN THE ROAD AND INTENTION.
TO CLOSE THIS STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE.
BY FEE INCREASES.
FROM THE PEOPLE WHO USE THE DMV.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT INCREASE.
FEES AND GETS US THROUGH -- THAT
THE THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD SO THAT
IS OUR PROPOSAL IS NOT TO
INCREASE FEES AND A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD.
OKAY BUT THAT STILLDOES NOT
ADDRESS THE FACT THAT YOU COULD
BE FUNDING MUCH MORE DMV
ACTIVITY MUCH MORE C. H. P.
ACTIVITY IF YOU'RE ZEROED OUT
EVERYTHING ELSE IS COMING OUT OF
THIS BOUNCE.
AND THAT'S NOT BEING PROPOSED.
AGAIN. TO ME THIS FEELS LIKE.
BUDGET TRICKERY IT FEELS LIKE --
SHELL GAME.
ARE WE HAVE A FUND THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE FEET PAIRS OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE DMV. TO DO A
VERY APPROPRIATE THINGS.
THE DMV CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
OVER TIME WE ADD UP AND ADD UP
MORE AND MORE DRAW DOWN. FOR
PURPOSES THAT ARE UTTERLY
UNRELATED TO THE FEES THAT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA OR PAY.
I JUST THINK IT ADDS INEVITABLY
IF WE DON'T MAKE SUBSTANTIAL --
CUTS AND WHAT ALL THIS
DISCRETIONARY STUFF.
WE'RE GONNA END UP I THINK WITH
THE INCREASES IN FRONT OF US.
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT I
WORRY ABOUT THAT BECAUSE IT'S
TOO EASY TO GO TO THE FEE PAIRS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
FIX STUFF LIKE THIS [inaudible]
MS RIVER [inaudible]
I'M.
I ALSO WANT TO COMMENT ON
POTENTIAL FEE INCREASES I KNOW
YOU ANSWERED THE QUESTION BUT I
KNOW ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
HERE FROM THE LA -- WAS TO TEACH
TO GENERATE ADDITIONAL REVENUES
BY INCREASING -- VEHICLE
REGISTRATION AND OTHER FEES --
YOU KNOW I HAVE CONCERNS WITH
HOW THAT IMPACTS LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES -- ESPECIALLY AFTER
WE JUST RAISED FEES THROUGH SB
ONE ON REGISTRATION FEES -- SO I
I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS IS OUR
LAST RESORT IN TERMS OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE DON'T
INCREASE FEES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE TELLER COMMENTS
NOT A QUESTION UNLESS YOU FEEL
LIKE IT AFTER RESPOND.
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY A FROM
FROM DALLAS OFFICE I WILL WITHIN
YOUR AGENDA IN OUR REPORT WORK
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
SORT OF ONE OF THE AVAILABLE
OPTIONS FOR LATER SO WE'RE NOT
RECOMMENDING.
A INCREASE IN A VEHICLE
REGISTERED WHAT WE TRY TO LAY ON
ARE NOW SAYS WHAT WE'RE ALL
DIFFERENT LEVERS YOU COULD PLAY
WITH TO ADDRESS THAT THE ISSUE.
GREAT WELL THANK YOU I THINK
THAT'LL CONCLUDE THIS -- ISSUE
AND WE HAVE -- ISSUE SEVEN
REMAINING AND WE'LL DO PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER THAT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AGAIN I'M
KATHLEEN WEB ACTING DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OR VEHICLES AND WITH
ME IS ROBBIE CROCKETT DIPPY
DIRECTOR OF MINISTRIES SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS FIVE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL REQUEST BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
I UNDERSTAND THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THESE
OPEN SO I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE A
QUICK OVERVIEW.
OF EACH AND THEN WE'LL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
YES AND LET ME JUST SAY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OF FOLKS WHO ARE HERE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE ITEM LEFT THAT --
SUGGESTS A AN ACTION ON THE PART
OF THE COMMITTEE -- BUT RATHER
THAN WAIT UNTIL THE END OF THE
AGENDA PEOPLE HAVE PLACES TO GO
WELL THAT AND THERE'S NO REASON
WHY WE CAN'T DO THIS WILL HOLD
ISSUE.
ALL OF ISSUE NINE OPEN -- SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN ATTEND TO THE
BUSINESS THAT THEY NEED TO
ATTEND TO ON THIS BUSY DAY.
SORRY FOR THE INTERRUPTION A
OKAY THE FIRST REQUEST IS FOR
THE WALNUT CREEK FIELD OFFICE
RELOCATION THE CURRENT FIELD
OFFICE IS THE LEAST DISABILITY
THAT IS CHANGED OWNERSHIP.
AND THE NEW OWNERS ARE NOT
WILLING TO INCLUDE DMV IN THEIR
FUTURE PLANS FOR THE SPACE THE
CURRENT LEASE WAS SET TO EXPIRE.
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND DG'S DTS WAS ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE A TWO YEAR LEASE
EXTENSION WITH THE BUILDING
OWNERS WHILE DMV LOOKS FOR A NEW
LOCATION.
THE DEPARTMENTS REQUESTING A ONE
TIME FUNDING OF ABOUT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT IN FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY TO PROCURE A NEW
LEASE FACILITY THAT WILL ALLOW
DVD CONTINUE PROVIDE SERVICES IN
THE WALNUT CREEK AREA. FOR THOSE
CUSTOMERS -- OUR SECOND REQUEST
IS FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THE
DMV IS REQUESTING THREE MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. FOR FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THE CURRENT COMPARTMENT OR THE
DEPARTMENT HAS CURRENT LIST OF
NINETY TWO PROJECTS -- AND
SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION OF
PENDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS.
THE THREE MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
WILL FUND THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
PROJECTS WHICH INCLUDE SIXTEEN
ROOF REPLACEMENTS.
AND TWO H. BACK REPLACEMENTS.
THE NEXT THREE REQUESTS ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS THE DELIVERY IF HE IS
REQUESTING ONE POINT ONE MILLION.
FUND -- WERE WORKING THE DRYING
PHASE OF THE CONTINUING REEDLEY
FIELD OFFICE REPLACEMENT PROJECT.
THE REALLY FIELD OFFICE IS A
FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD FACILITY THAT
IS UNDERSIZED AND HAS NOT BEEN
PROPERLY MAINTAINED BY THE
LESSOR.
THE CURRENT LEASE WAS DUE TO
EXPIRE IN FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TGS WAS ABLE TO WORK WITH A
LESSER TO EXTEND THE LEASE UNTIL
DECEMBER. TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
TIME FOR A NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
FACILITY TO BE READY TO OPEN.
THIS PROJECT WILL PROVIDE A NEW
SAFE APPROPRIATELY SIZED
OFFICIALLY DESIGN ZERO NET
ENERGY FACILITY.
THE FINAL TWO CAPITAL LA
PROPOSALS ARE ACTUALLY
REQUESTING TO RIVER FUNDING BACK
TO THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT.
WE ARE QUESTION RIVER THE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING FOR TWO
PROJECTS BACK TO THE NBA.
WE ARE VERY FIFTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION BACK TO THE NBA FOR THE
DESIGN BILL PHASE OF THE
INGLEWOOD FIELD OFFICE REPLACE
OUR PROJECT.
AND WE ARE REVERTING NINE POINT
SEVEN MILLION BACK TO THE NBA.
FOR THE DESIGN CONSTRUCTION
PERIMETER FENCES AT TWENTY STATE
OWNED DMV FIELD OFFICE LOCATIONS.
IN WITH THAT I TURN IT OVER AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE -- LET'S PROCEED --
TO LA ODIO AFTER NO COMMENTS --
LET'S PROCEED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUES. SIX AND SEVEN SEEING
NONE -- MS WEBB THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR APPEARING HERE AFTER
YOUR LONG DAY YESTERDAY JUST
BEFORE YOU LEAVE I HAVE ONE
QUICK COMMENT -- WITHOUT YOU'RE
GONNA GET AWAY -- REALLY I JUST
WANTED TO REFLECT ON YOUR STATED
INTENTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TERMS OF REFORMING SYSTEMS AND
BRINGING MORE EFFICIENCIES AND
TAKING CORRECTIVE ACTION FOR THE
MANY -- ISSUES THAT -- THAT
EXISTED DMV -- I AM -- YOU KNOW.
INTENT IN PROVIDING -- A HIGH
LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD -- AND HOPEFULLY YOU
WILL BE CONFIRMED AT A ON A ON A
PERMANENT BASIS BUT AT THE
DEPARTMENT MOVES FORWARD.
IMPLEMENTING THESE KINDS OF
REFORMS LOOKS LIKE WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT -- I I
I I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE'LL
BE LOOKING FOR YOU TO PROVIDE US
WITH BENCHMARKS -- AS I KNOW
YOU'RE INTENDING TO DO AND WE'RE
GONNA WANNA HOLD YOU TO THOSE
BENCHMARKS IN.
A PROVIDE YOU AS I THINK -- WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO ACHIEVE THEM BECAUSE I THINK --
THE OTHER PROBLEMS THE
DEPARTMENT IS FACING OUR RESULT
OF MULTI FACETED -- TO ISSUES
THAT HAVE ARISEN IN ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES AS OUR LACK OF PROVIDING
PROPER FUNDING CUTS -- FOR THE
MANY INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE
ASKED THE DMB TO FALL OVER THE
YEARS AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE UNDERSTAND FROM YOU AND
FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT WHAT THE
ACTUAL NEEDS ARE -- SO THAT WE
CAN -- EITHER PROVIDER NOT
PROVIDE THE PROPER LEVEL OF
FUNDING BUT IF WE DON'T DO THAT --
WE NEED TO BE HELD A CON
ACCOUNTABLE ALSO IS THIS IS A BI
LATERAL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO ACHIEVE
BETTER RESULTS IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
SORRY I MISSED MOST OF THAT
MEETING YESTERDAY SO I DIDN'T
HAVE A CHANCE TO TO MAKE MY
COMMENTS THAT.
AND MISTER REED YOU ARE LATE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I AM IN
CANNELLA SPEAK ANYWAY.
THANK YOU I I WAS LOOKING AT THE
WRONG PAGE.
I WAS AGAIN THE COVER SHEET IS
AT ISSUE SIX I SAID WELL THAT'S
NOT AND THE HR TRUTH THAT I HAD
NOT HEARD OF AN ISSUE EIGHT NINE
ARE YOU.
I'M HERE TO BE IN THE NBA.
OKAY OKAY NBA ACCOUNT FLOOR IS
YOUR BANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ERIN
READ.
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HIGH WITH COMMON.
OF I'VE BEEN REPRESENTING THEM
FOR FORTY ONE YEARS SO I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE NBA COUNT.
OVER ALL THOSE YEARS AND A
MILLION AND I THINK WE'VE BEEN
FIGHTING A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
LITERALLY FOR ALMOST ALL THAT
TIME -- IS IT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT
IT'S A WAY WHERE IT'S BEEN.
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAD TO STEP
IN PERIODICALLY AND ADJUST THE
FEES BECAUSE IT WAS A FLAT
DOLLAR AMOUNT IN THE STATUTE.
SIR EVERY NOW AND THEN YOU HAD
TO RAISE IT BY FIVE DOLLARS OR
TEN DOLLARS -- SO FINDING JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO YOU INDEX TO TO
THE COLA BUT THAT'S RELATIVELY
LOW INFLATION IS LIKE TWO TWO
AND A HALF PERCENT.
A AND THAT DOESN'T KEEP UP THE
COST OF FUEL.
I MEAN GET YOU WE KNOW HOW
VOLATILE THAT IS AND IS HEADED
TO FOUR DOLLARS A GALLON.
FOR US I KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
MAIS.
LESS THAN THAT THE COST OF
SALARIES ACOSTA RENT AND
MORTGAGES AND PAYMENTS ON
EVERYTHING THEY THEY OPERATE.
WILL WILL NECESSITATE YOU TO
HAVE TO DO ANOTHER.
SOME DOLLAR INCREASE IN THE AND
THE THE QUESTION IS WHEN ARE YOU
GOING TO DO IT -- BUT YOU'LL BE
FACED WITH THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
TRYING TO PATCH IT UP WITH.
YOU KNOW.
STOPPING THE LEAGUE FROM THE DMV
MONEY THAT'S REYES OUT OF
SELLING INFORMATION TO INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT SORT OF THING --
THAT MONEY SHOULD STAY IN THE
NBA IN MY OPINION.
BUT IT'S BEEN TAKEN FOR DECADES
NOT JUST RECENTLY THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR AS LONG AS I CAN
RECALL -- SO I'M HERE TO SAY
THAT THE CHP IS LEAN IS ANY
DEPARTMENT YOU'LL REVIEW.
I CHALLENGE ANY OTHER DEPARTMENT
TO SHOW WHERE THEY HAVE FEWER
EMPLOYEES AND THEY HAD TEN YEARS
AGO.
C. H. P. HAS EIGHTY THREE LESS
OFFICERS TODAY AND HAD TEN YEARS
AGO.
THE POPULATION HAS INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF CARS ACCIDENTS THE
MILEAGE DEATH RATE HAS INCREASED.
THIS IS THE OFFICERS DOING SO
MUCH MORE WITH A LOT LESS.
BUT NO THE DEPARTMENT IS GOING
THROUGH THAT -- THAT I AND I'VE
LOOKED A LOT OF THEM AND MOST OF
THEM HAVE HAD INCREASES.
WE HAD THREE HUNDRED MORE
OFFICERS AND WE HAVE TODAY.
DURING THE BROWN ADMINISTRATION
BUT THEY WERE CUT DURING THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
THEY WERE NEVER RESTORED.
NEVER NOT.
ONE SO WE'RE LESS OFFICERS TODAY
AND TEN YEARS AGO SO I'M HERE TO
SAY THAT THAT WE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT -- AGAIN
THE MILEAGE DEATH RATE IS UP OF
THE DEPARTMENT CAN'T SAY WHAT
I'M SAYING BECAUSE THEY'RE BOUND.
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BUT I CAN TELL YOU FREELY THAT
IS A PROBLEM AND THE OFFICERS
ARE.
REALLY STRESSED.
WE JUST HAD AN OFFICER KILLED
LAST SATURDAY PROBABLY NOBODY
KNOWS BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN THE
NEWSPAPERS BUT AS SERGEANT WAS
RUN OVER AND KILLED.
LAST SATURDAY THAT MAKES THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
OFFICERS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY SINCE NINETEEN TWENTY NO
OTHERLAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
IN THIS STATE HAS THE DEATH RATE
NEARLY AS HIGH.
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO WHAT THE CHP
LOSSES ARE.
SO I IMPLORE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT.
AND YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU CAN.
HELP US RESOLVE THAT THE BILL
LAST YEAR WAS VETOED THE VETO
MESSAGE SIMPLY SAID DO IT IN THE
BUDGET.
THAT'S WHAT THE VETO MESSAGE
SAID SO FINANCES NOT PROPOSING
IT THEY'RE NOT SUPPORTING IT SO
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT AND WHAT DATA THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THAT.
THE IT'S NOT WHAT I'M SEEING.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THAT
WAS THE UNDERLYING RATIONALE FOR
ME TO ASK -- MY QUESTION EARLIER
IN THE IN THE MEETING.
I APPRECIATED YOUR QUESTION
THANK YOU.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR THIS
PORTION OF THE HEARING -- WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
DEPARTMENT OF THE DAY THANK YOU
FOR BEING SO.
PATIENT WE'RE GONNA.
HERE NOW FROM A CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. TO HAVE ISSUES
EIGHT AND NINE AND AGAIN WILL
TAKE US SINCE BOTH OF THESE ARE
HOLD OPEN -- WE WILL -- I HEAR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE CONCLUSION
OF ISSUE NINE WELCOME SIR
[inaudible] ONE GOOD MORNING
GERMAN WOMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMISSIONER
WARNED STANLEY AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE
YOU THIS MORNING.
AND SPEAK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL'S TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET -- BEFORE I
WANT TO I BEGIN I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU PERSONALLY AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT NOT POURING OF
CONCERN. FOR SERGEANT STEVEN
LIKE KHAN WHO WAS KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY.
ON SATURDAY APRIL SIXTH IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ON INTERSTATE.
FIFTEEN VERY WAS STRUCK AND
KILLED BY A DRUNK DRIVER.
THAT HE SACRIFICE FOR ALL OF US
AND HE WAS A HE WAS A GREAT MAN.
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE GOOD WORK OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN AND ITS C. H. B..
AND OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS GOOD
STEWARDS OF THE FUNDING HAS
PROVIDED US.
ALSO WANT TO SUPPRESS MY THANKS
TO YOUR STAFF THAT THIS HELPED
US GET READY FOR THIS PROCESS.
FIRST I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
CAPITAL OUTLAY IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
WE HAVE FIVE PROPOSALS ON
DISCUSSION TODAY REGARDING
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
BECAUSE THE VARIOUS CONSTRAINTS
ON THE MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT WE'RE
PROPOSING THE SUSPENSION.
OF THE FACILITY REPLACEMENT
PROJECT FOR THE QUINCY AND THE
SANTA ANNA AREA OFFICES.
THIS WOULD RESULT IN REVERSION
OF THIRTY SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS BACK TO THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT. FOR THE
EL CENTRO HE WORKED AND SAN
BERNARDINO AREA OFFICE FACILITY
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS THE NBA TO
THE PUBLIC BUILDINGS
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS.
STE THESE THREE PROJECTS WERE
PREVIOUS APPROVED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
AND EACH OF THESE BUILDING SITES
OF ALREADY BEEN ACQUIRED.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE
CONSTRAINTS ON THE NBA THE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN PLACED ON
HOLD UNTIL OFFERING ALTERNATIVE
FUNDING IS SECURED.
AND THAT STATED EARLIER WILL
DEFER TO OUR PARTNERS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
TO PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION
REGARDING THAT.
IN REGARDS -- TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE ARE REQUESTING
FIVE MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. TO COMPLETE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY PROJECTS FROM OUR LIST
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS.
DUE TO THE AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
MANY SEATS BE FULFILLED
FACILITIES NEED MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS.
CURRENTLY THE SIEGE PETER FOR
MAKING PROJECT.
LIST CONSIST OF OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PROJECTS.
AT A TOTAL COST OF OVER FORTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THE REQUESTED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO FROM THE COMPLETE
THE MOST CRITICAL PROJECTS.
FURTHER NEGLECTING AT THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE EXPOSED TO
SEIZE P. RESTA TO LIABILITY IN
SERIOUS INJURY TO DEPARTMENT
POLICE.
AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AND I WILL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE LA -- NO COMMENTS
THERE -- OBVIOUSLY THE THE TOPIC
WE JUST DISCUSSED IS VERY
RELEVANT HERE SO WOULDN'T NEED
REPEAT OURSELVES -- BUT WE WILL --
CONTINUE.
BY HOLDING THIS OPEN -- TO THINK
ABOUT THAT ISSUE AND ASK
QUESTIONS -- LAST ISSUE IS THE
TASK FORCE ON ORGANIZED CRIME.
YES SIR -- THE RETAIL THEFT TASK
FORCE.
WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING FIVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
THE REGIONAL PROPERTY CRIMES
TASK FORCE IS DIRECTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN ASSEMBLY BILL -- AB.
TEN SIXTY FIVE ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL RETAIL FEDERATION
ORGANIZED CRIME COST UNITED
STATES RETAILERS NEARLY THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS HERE.
RETAILERS NATIONWIDE HAVE BEEN
TARGETED BY ORGANIZED CRIME AND
SOPHISTICATED SHOPLIFTING RINGS.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS CONSISTENT
TEAMS OF THEMES THAT STILL FROM
RETAIL STORES AND THEN BRING THE
STOLEN GOODS TO A CENTRAL
LOCATION.
WERE THERE ARE SOLD ONLINE OR
SHIPPED TO ANOTHER LOCATION.
HISTORICALLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
RESPOND TO THESE PROBLEMS
INDEPENDENTLY.
AND ACCORDING TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB TEN SIXTY
FIVE TO SEE EACH BE WILL BE
CHOIR WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
ESTABLISH REGIONAL PROPERTY
CRIMES TASK FORCE.
IN COORDINATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO ENHANCE
AND IMPROVE CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE TO ORGANIZED CRIME.
IN RETAIL.
LAST YEAR THE SIEGE BE COMBINED
EFFORTS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE SAN FRANCISCO
DA'S OFFICE.
AND UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE
TO CONDUCT A CON A COMPLEX
RETAIL THEFT INVESTIGATION IN
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS OPERATION FOCUS ON THE TH
AFTER OVER NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STOLEN PROPERTY.
AND RESULTED IN THE ESTIMATES OF
EIGHTEEN ARREST WARRANTS
BREAKING UP THIS THEIR BRING.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST LIMITED TO SAN
FRANCISCO WE WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO LOOK AT
CRIME DATA. TO IDENTIFY THE
WORST PROBLEM AREAS.
AND WE WILL WORK WITH THE LA
AGENCIES TO INCLUDE THE LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IS TO
DETERMINE THE BEST AREAS TO
DEVELOP THESE RESOURCES AND
FOCUS OUR COMBINED EFFORTS.
WE IDENTIFIED AGENCIES.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO
AS I STATED BEFORE THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN THE DEAN'S OFFICE
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY DA --
ESCONDIDO POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE LONG BEACH THE LA POLICE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
AN INTEREST TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS TASK FORCE. TO COMPLY WITH
AB TEN SIXTY FIVE WE'RE
PROPOSING.
THE FUNDING OF SIXTEEN POSITION
ALONG WITH ASSOCIATED COSTS.
WE'RE ASKING FOR THREE SERGEANTS
POSITION TO SUPERVISE --
OPERATIONAL UNITS AND NINE
OFFICER POSITIONS -- TO CONDUCT
SPECIALIZE INVESTIGATION AND
ENFORCEMENT TARGETING ORGANIZED
RETAIL THAT.
THESE OFFICERS THIS ORDER WILL
WORK.
WITH THE DOJ AND LOCAL AGENCIES%
TO COMBAT ORGANIZED CRIME.
THE REQUEST WILL ALSO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR ONE ANALYST POSITION
PROVIDE STATEWIDE PROGRAM
COORDINATION AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT TO THE TASK FORCE.
ALONG WITH THREE OFFICE
TECHNICIAN POSITION TO SUPPORT
THE DAILY ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS OF THE TASK FORCE.
WE'RE ALSO ASKING THE ABILITY TO
CONTRACT WITH DOJ AGENTS WHEN
FEASIBLE. ONE SAID THIS UP TO
THIS SPECIFIC WORKING AREAS ARE
IDENTIFIED THE AVAILABILITY OF
THE STEEL J. AGENTS AND THEIR
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
TASK FORCE WILL BE DETERMINED.
THIS PROPOSAL WILL ESTABLISH
RESOURCES INCLUDING PERSONNEL
EQUIPMENT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT.
NECESSARY FOR THE SIEGE BE TO
FILL THE REQUIREMENTS AS
OUTLINED.
IN AB [inaudible]
TEN SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS ON ON THIS ITEM --
THIS IS A A NEW FUNCTION -- FOR
FOR C. H. P. CAN YOU GIVE US
SOME -- FEEDBACK ON HOW -- YOU
INTEGRATE AT A YOU KNOW AN
ENTIRELY NEW FUNCTION AND TO THE
ON GOING -- WORKLOAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
WELL THE GOOD THING ABOUT THE
SIEGE BE WE WORK IN OTHER TASK
FORCES IN -- VEHICLE THAT TASK
FORCES -- COUNTER TERRORIST TASK
FORCES THE DRUG TASK FORCES SO
WE UNDERSTAND A FRAMEWORK OF
PUTTING TASK FORCES TOGETHER
THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT'S
VERY VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE IS
RELATED TO RETAIL.
PASTORE SO WE DO HAVE SOMEONE ON
THE WHEELS YEAH ALTHOUGH MAYBE
ONE PART OF IT IS IN THE HEART
OF IT IS WHEN THAT WHEN THAT
WHEN THE GUESTS ARE STOLEN THEIR
TRANSPORTER LIKE YOU SAID THAT
SOME OF THEM ARE SOLD ONLINE IT
BUT THEN SOME OF THEM.
ARE TRANSPORTED TO OTHER PLACES
WHERE THEY'RE SHIPPED OUT FROM
THERE.
AND THAT'S WHERE CH BECOMES AT
BEST THAT'S WHERE WE COME IN AND
ALSO -- ON A STATEWIDE BASIS
COORDINATING WITH THE OJ.
AND THE OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
YES I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS TO KIND
OF ADD ON TO YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST IS THAT THERE IS A
BUDGET REQUEST THAT WAS
SUBMITTED BY DOJ THAT WILL BE
UNDER CONSIDERATION UNDER THE
PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET COMMITTEE
IT'S FOR ONE POSITION AND THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND YEAH THIS WHOLE TOPICS
A LITTLE BIT TO UNIQUE TO US UP
VERY VERY MUCH.
SO WE THOUGHT IT ALL RIGHT I
STILL LIKE IT.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
JUST TO PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
SO THAT YOU CAN SEE KIND OF THAT
KIND OF COMPLETE PICTURE.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS ON THE TWO
POINT ONE MILLION TO CONTRACT
WITH DOJ OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE ARE STILL KIND OF
SIGNIFICANT DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
WHAT THAT ROLE WOULD LOOK LIKE.
AND IT'S UNCERTAIN THE EXTENT TO
WHICH DOJ WILL BE PROVIDING
RESOURCES AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE COMMITTEE WILL WANT TO
MAYBE GET FIRM ANSWERS ON BEFORE
KIND OF TAKING ACTION ON THIS
ITEM SO I THINK THOSE ARE OUR
COMMENTS.
GREAT THANK YOU THAT THE WOULD
BE WELL ADVISED TO DO THAT.
YES PLEASE IF I COULD RESPOND TO
TO VALLEY AS COMMENTS OF COME
PART OF THE REASON WHY THIS TWO
POINT ONE MILLION IS BUILT IN ON
C. H. P. SIDE IS BECAUSE IT IS
C. H. P. WHO'S THAT PASSED WITH
THE WITH.
LEADING THIS TASK FORCE AND SO.
TO THE EXTENT OF THE OF THE
LEGISLATION UNDER THE
LEGISLATION YES -- TO THE EXTENT
THAT DOJ RESOURCES AREN'T
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THIS MONEY
WOULD BE IN C. H. P.'S BUDGET
THEY COULD SUPPLEMENT WITH
ADDITIONAL OFFICERS ON THE TASK
FORCE IF.
THE OJ COULDN'T PROVIDE THEM SO
THAT'S PART OF HIS MY WAS
STRUCTURED THAT WAY IF YOU WANNA --
A COMMENT ON THE ISSUE REGARDING
THE A SUNSET DATE EXTENSION AND
THE YOU KNOW THERE WAS A REQUEST
TO REJECT THE PROJECT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WITH WHICH
WE WON'T DO TODAY BUT IF.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
THAT.
I WOULD SAY IF THIS COMMITTEE
CHOOSES TO REJECT THE TRIBAL
LANGUAGE WE WOULD WORK WITH --
THE STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
RESOURCES ARE ADJUSTED TO ALIGN
WITH THAT ACTION.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON EITHER
ISSUES.
EIGHT FOUR NINE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IRAN ALL TOMORROW WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION.
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE FUNDING
FOR THE ORGANIZED RETAIL CRIME
TASK FORCE AS WELL AS THE
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET DATE
THANK YOU. TO HAVE ANY ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF TARGET IN THE HOME
DEPOT ALSO IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
THE FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THIS
HUGE PAN DOJ HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRAILER BUILDING WHICH IS A FILE
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION -- FOR INCLUDING
THIS IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT CLOSES THE PUBLIC HEARING
AND WE HAVE -- SOME -- WHERE
WERE GONNA FINISH WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE FOR BEING PATIENT
I NOTICED YOU WAITED THROUGH THE
AN?
ENTIRE HEARING.
HOPE YOU LEARNED SOMETHING FROM
ALL THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS -- MS
REVERSE SO WE'VE GOT SOME --
VOTES FOR YOU.
ON ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE
NUMBER THREE THE MOTION WAS TO
APPROVE [inaudible]
REGIS [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
APOLOGIZE GARCIA [inaudible]
THANKS [inaudible]
THAT'S IT.
GREAT -- THAT CONCLUDES OUR
VOTES -- AND THAT BRINGSUS TO
THE CONCLUSION OF OUR MEETING
THANK YOU ALL FOR ATTENDING AND
PARTICIPATING WE'RE ADJOURNED